This Friday, grab your friends. Nova Kane? I thought you'd be dead by now. Get to the theater and experience the movie audiences are calling. An adrenaline rush of a good time. It's a big screen blast. Find a badass. I know, alright. Nova Kane. Friday. I'm not going back to university to be your friend.
这周五，约上你的朋友。诺娃·凯恩？我以为你早就死了。去影院体验这部被观众称为充满肾上腺素的爽片的电影。这是一部大银幕上的狂欢。找个狠角色。我懂，好吧。诺娃·凯恩。周五。我才不会回大学当你的朋友。
I'm going so I can get Uber One for students. It saves you on Uber and Uber Eats. I'm there for zero dollar delivery fee on cheeseburgers, up to 5% off smoothies and 5% Uber credits back on rides. Just to be clear, I'm there for savings, not whatever you think university is for. Get Uber One for Students, a membership to save on Uber and Uber Eats.
我去是为了用针对学生的 Uber One。它能帮你省下 Uber 和 Uber Eats 的钱。我就是冲着芝士汉堡零配送费、奶茶最高 5% 的折扣以及行程最高 5% 的 Uber 积分返现去的。声明一下，我是去省钱的，不管你觉得上大学是干什么的。订购针对学生的 Uber One，一个能在 Uber 和 Uber Eats 上省钱的会员。
With deals this good, everyone wants to be a student. Join for just $4.99 a month. Savings may vary. Eligibility and member terms apply. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you.
优惠力度这么大，谁都想当学生了。每月只需 4.99 美元即可加入。优惠情况可能会有所不同。适用资格和会员条款。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极办公室爱好者播客。
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello everyone. Hi there. What are we doing today? We're breaking down another Peacock Superfan episode today.
每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量 VFF 故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是 Office Ladies 6.0。大家好。大家好。我们今天要做什么？我们今天要剖析另一集孔雀台（Peacock）超级粉丝版。
That's right, it's season two, episode four, written by BJ Novak, directed by Ken Quapus, it's the fire. Angela, I understand you spoke to Ken Quapus a little about this episode. I did. I just want you all to know that if you need to call someone who instantly makes you feel like everything in the world's gonna be okay, it's Ken Quapus.
没错，这是第二季第四集，由 BJ·诺瓦克编剧，肯·夸普斯执导，也就是《火灾》。安吉拉，我听说你跟肯·夸普斯聊了聊关于这一集的事情。是的。我只想让大家知道，如果你需要打电话给一个能瞬间让你觉得世事皆安的人，那就是肯·夸普斯。
This is so true. His voice just immediately, it's like a hug. Yes, he's like a giant walking warm hug. Mm-hmm. Well everyone, we skipped this episode when we did our second drinks and the Peacock Superfan episode has about 10 minutes of added material. And we know this is a fan favorite episode. And you know, Dave Rogers interview got me really excited about these Peacock superfan episodes. I had not watched them before we watched the Hot Girl superfan and then talking to Dave, I was like, okay, I'm in.
确实如此。他的声音立刻就能让人感觉像是一个拥抱。没错，他就像一个巨大的行走的温暖拥抱。嗯。好吧，大家，我们在录制第二杯特调时跳过了这一集，孔雀台超级粉丝版大约有 10 分钟的追加素材。我们知道这是粉丝最爱的一集。你知道，戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）的采访让我对这些孔雀台超级粉丝版兴奋不已。在我们看《辣妹》超级粉丝版之前我还没看过，跟戴夫聊过之后，我就想，好吧，我加入。
Well, you know, you just hear the care that he's really putting into them. And so I'm excited to see his work. Same. And there are also a lot of things that we did not cover the first time we broke this down. I'm noticing as we're going through these with our second drinks that our breakdowns are very, very good. But for example, around this time, I didn't have any centipede effects. I know. So this time I reached out to Kent Sabornak and he gave me a few good tidbits from the
嗯，你知道的，你能听到他真正投入其中的用心。所以我很期待看到他的作品。我也是。而且我们第一次剖析这一集时，还有很多内容没有涵盖。我注意到当我们带着第二杯特调重温这些时，我们的剖析非常非常棒。但举个例子，大约在这个时候，我没有任何关于蜈蚣的特效。我懂。所以这次我联系了肯·萨博纳克（Kent Sabornak），他从制作层面给我提供了一些好的花絮。
production side of things. Well you know in the early days of the podcast we were still figuring out what is this podcast, how do we share this information and I think we got better at just researching and digging and finding new information as we went. I agree. But before we break down this episode we've got some Top of Show shares for you. Yeah. And my Top of Show share is a belated thank you.
嗯，你知道的，在播客的早期，我们还在摸索这个播客是什么，我们该如何分享这些信息，随着时间的推移，我觉得我们在不断研究、挖掘和寻找新信息方面做得越来越好了。我同意。但在我们剖析这一集之前，我们有一些节目开场分享要带给大家。对的，我的节目开场分享是一声迟来的感谢。
We have received just some of the loveliest things from you all. So much mail. So much mail. You guys, I mean, on a personal note, your cards to me after the announcement of my breast cancer diagnosis have absolutely meant the world to me. I mean, just the kindness, the care, the specificity, I just appreciated all of it. Yeah. And also in going through our mail, there are some items that just
我们收到了大家送来的最美好的东西。好多信件。好多信件。你们知道的，就我个人而言，在我的乳腺癌诊断公告发布后，你们写给我的卡片对我来说意义重大。我是说，那些善意、关怀和具体的话语，我都无比感激。是的，而且在整理信件时，有些物品真的让我们印象深刻，我们把它们用在了新的办公空间里。
really have stood out to us that we have used in our new workspace. Yes, you all are making our workspace feel so warm and more personal. Yeah. I wanted to share about two things and we're gonna do this more often. Yes, because we are finally having the opportunity to go through this mail. It's so moving. It's like what Jenna said, it's the care that you're putting into what you send us. Yes, so here are the two things I wanted to shout out today.
是的，你们让我们的办公空间变得如此温馨、更有个性。是的，我想分享两件事，以后我们会更频繁地这样做。是的，因为我们终于有机会整理这些信件了。太感人了。就像珍娜说的，这是你们投入到送给我们的东西中的心思。是的，所以这是今天要表扬的两件事。
First of all, Kaitlyn made these beautiful stained glass pieces for us. So pretty. She made a loaf of bread for me. She made a hummingbird for Angela. But then she made us one that is an office theme with a teapot and a beet and a stapler and jello in stained glass, everybody.
首先，凯特琳（Kaitlyn）为我们制作了这些漂亮的彩绘玻璃作品。太漂亮了。她给我做了一条面包。她为安吉拉做了一只蜂鸟。然后她还给我们做了一个办公室主题的彩绘玻璃，里面有茶壶、甜菜、订书机和果冻，大家快看。
We have hung them on the windows in the office. Yes. And the light comes through them and they reflect all this beautiful light. And it's, I can't believe, like, how do you even make that? I don't know. I don't know. But beautiful, beautiful.
我们把它们挂在办公室的窗户上了。是的。光线透过它们折射出所有这些美丽的亮光。而且，我简直不敢相信，这到底是怎么做出来的？我不知道。我不知道。但真的很美，很美。
And then we also got just the sweetest hand-stitched tea towel, you know, that you would like wipe your hands on after you wash your hands, a kitchen towel. Right. Stitched with office ladies. It reminds me of the kind of gifts like my aunt would do. Like she would make little things like that for us. Well, it is from Harper and Angela. Here's her letter. First of all, here's how she addressed her letter with her tea towel, which we have put in our kitchen here, by the way. It says, Jenna and Angela, Pam and Angela, Lady and Lady, Beasley and Martin, Pamela and Ding Dong and Booster Seat,
然后我们还收到了最甜蜜的手工缝制茶巾，你知道的，就是洗完手后用来擦手的厨房毛巾。没错。上面绣着“Office Ladies”。这让我想起我姑姑会做的那种礼物。比如她会为我们制作这样的小物件。嗯，这是哈珀（Harper）和安吉拉送的。这是她的信。首先，这是她在茶巾上写信的称呼方式，顺便说一句，我们把它放在了这里的厨房里。上面写着：“珍娜和安吉拉，帕姆和安吉拉，女士和女士，比斯利和马丁，帕梅拉与叮咚和安全座椅，德布，你这个调侃鬼和巫毒妈妈朱朱，帕米和猴子，办公室女士们。”
Deb, you taunt and voodoo mama juju, Pammy and Monkey, the office ladies. Wow. That's awesome. So thorough. This is like our Game of Thrones title, like first of her name. Yes, yes. I love it. Here is what Harper said, Guatemala being supported by friends, family, and my church in Florida. It's been an experience I cannot put into words. I'm just so grateful to be a small
哇。太棒了。真全面。这就像我们的《权力的游戏》头衔一样，比如“某某名字的第一世”。是的，是的。我很喜欢。哈珀是这么说的：“在佛罗里达州的朋友、家人和教会的支持下，这段在危地马拉的经历是我无法用言语表达的。我非常感激能成为在危地马拉为几个孩子改变命运的事业中的一小部分。为了筹款，我亲手设计、绘制并缝制了这些定制毛巾，送给任何想要支持宣教工作的人。我想把其中一条送给我最喜欢的女士们，作为送给你们两人的礼物。”哈珀接着说道：“我出生时患有一种罕见的皮肤病。作为参考，我经常把自己比作一块巧克力曲奇饼干。”
part of a ministry changing lives for a few kids here in Guatemala. As a fundraiser, I hand design, draw, and stitch these custom towels for anyone who would want to support mission work. I wanted to send one to some of my favorite ladies as a gift to you both." Harper went on to say, I was born with a rare skin condition. For reference, I often compare myself to a chocolate chip cookie.
我的头上脚下长满了大大的雀斑。这种病情导致了许多霸凌和取笑，让我一生中的大部分时间都感到非常孤独。《办公室》是我在初中、高中和成年早期背着沉重的书包感到孤独时，能紧紧抓住带给我快乐的事物之一。谢谢安吉拉、珍娜以及整个《办公室》的演员和剧组，影响了至少一个生命。
I'm covered head to toe in large freckles. This condition led to a lot of bullying, name calling, and made me feel very lonely throughout most of my life. The office was one of those things I could hold on to tight to bring me joy during those moments I had a heavy backpack in middle school, high school, and my early adult life. Thank you, Angela, Jenna, and the entire office cast and crew for impacting at least one life.
我相信我不是唯一的一个。”然后哈珀说：“顺便说一句，我一边缝这条毛巾一边刷完了第一季和第二季，我还能记起安吉拉在研究设计时对冰岛某个博物馆的深入探讨。”没错。我们得去，珍娜。我们得去。哈珀，非常感谢你。当我打开你的包裹时，我真的能看到缝线里倾注的爱意和心思，它太美了。我们非常感谢你，也要谢谢凯特琳。是的。听到你们大家的来信，阅读你们的故事，真的成了我们生活中的一大亮点，我们只想说谢谢。
I'm sure I'm not alone." And then Harper said, P.S. I've binged season one and two while stitching this towel and I can remember Angela deep diving a certain museum in Iceland while I was working on the design. Yep. We have to go, Jenna. We have to go. Harper, thank you so much. Immediately when I opened your package, I could really see the love and care that went into the stitching and it's beautiful. And we thank you so much and thank you, Caitlin, as well. Yes. Hearing from you all, it's really just such a bright spot in our lives, reading your
嗯，你知道的，我的节目开场分享就是受到这一集的启发。这是主线剧情之一。就是吉姆试图让德温特·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的所有员工在停车场等待时玩游戏。是的，他们很无聊。他在娱乐大家。我的朋友贝茜（Betsy）送了我一份礼物，是一个叫作《关于办公室》的游戏。
stories and we just thank you. Well, you know, my top of show share was inspired by this episode. It's one of the main storylines. It's when Jim is trying to get all the Dunder Mifflin employees to play games while they wait in the parking lot. Yes, they're bored. He's entertaining everyone. Well, my friend Betsy, as a gift gave me a game called All About the Office.
这是一个办公室问答游戏，我本以为自己玩这个肯定是个高手。我可不敢打包票。它分为几个类别，比如第一到第三季、第四到第六季。我想如果你们愿意的话，在这一集的过程中我们可以玩这个问答游戏。我太喜欢了。你告诉我这个想法后，我立刻就出去
It's an office trivia game and I thought for sure I would just be like a pro at it. I'm not so sure. It's divided into categories like seasons one through three, seasons four through six. I thought if you guys are up for it throughout this episode, we could play this quiz game. I love this. You told me this idea and I promptly went out
给大家买了一套抢答器。不仅仅是抢答器哦，你得告诉大家它们有什么特别之处。每个抢答器发出不同的声音。所以我们的听众能真正知道是谁第一个按响了抢答器。等等，我们是不是应该各自挑选自己的抢答器声音？对的。
and bought us buzzers everybody. Not just buzzers though, you have to tell them what makes them special. Each buzzer makes a different sound. So our listeners will really know who came in first with the buzz. So wait, should we each pick our buzzer sound? Yes.
萨姆和卡茜应该先选。嗯，它们的颜色不同，而且发出的声音也不同。那你们想要什么颜色？你们可以选择橙色、绿色、蓝色或紫色。我想要粉色，我想要紫色。好的。
Sam and Cassie should go first. Well, they're different colors and they all make a different sound. So what color do you guys want? You have a choice of orange, green, blue or purple. I want pink, I want purple. Okay. This is your sound then Sam Okay Cassie I'll take green green you are this
萨姆，那这就是你的声音了。好的，卡茜，我选绿色，绿色就是你这个。
And what do you want I'll go blue, okay That's you. Okay, and that leaves me with orange, which is ding-dong Here's the thing you you guys, with the trivia cards, the answer is listed right below the question. So I think we each have to take turns being the person that asked the question, for it to be fair. Does that make sense?
那你想要哪个？我选蓝色，好的。那就是你的了。好了，剩下的就是我的橙色了，声音是“叮咚”。有一说一，你们这帮人，问答卡上，答案就印在问题下方。所以我觉得为了公平起见，我们必须轮流当那个提问的人。这说得通吧？
Yeah, so why don't we do four rounds? We can spread it out throughout the episode. And why don't you be the asker first? Okay, I will be the asker. Do you have your buzzers ready? Yes. Buzzers ready. I'm going to ask four questions from the teapot category,
对啊，那我们为什么不进行四轮呢？我们可以把它贯穿到整集节目中。要不你先来当提问者？好的，我来当提问者。你们准备好抢答器了吗？准备好了。抢答器准备就绪。我要从“茶壶”类别里问四个问题，
which is seasons one through three, okay? Teapot category. Well, hey ladies and gentlemen, welcome to All About the Office, the ultimate trivia game. Are you ready? Yes, I have my buzzer. Question number one. In the Women's Appreciation episode,
也就是第一季到第三季，好吗？“茶壶”类别。各位女士先生，欢迎来到《关于办公室》，终极问答游戏。准备好了吗？是的，我的抢答器准备好了。问题一。在《妇女赞赏日》那一集里，
who was flashed in the office parking lot? Jenna, I heard Ding Dong first. Phyllis. That is correct. One point for me. One point for Jenna. Okay. In the Business School episode, Dwight caught a bat by trapping it in a bag on who's head? That is correct! Yes! One point for me! One point for Jenna. Okay.
谁在办公室停车场被人掀开风衣暴露了？珍娜，我最先听到的是叮咚。菲利斯。回答正确。我得一分。珍娜得一分。好的。在《商学院》那一集里，德怀特把一只蝙蝠装进袋子里套在了谁的头上？回答正确！耶！我得一分！珍娜得一分。好的。
In the Business School episode, Dwight caught a bat by trapping it in a bag on whose head? Cassie, I heard yours first. Meredith. One point for Cassie! That is correct! Oh, this is the fire! Okay. Okay.
在《商学院》那一集里，德怀特把一只蝙蝠装进袋子里套在了谁的头上？卡茜，我先听到你的声音。梅雷迪思。卡茜得一分！回答正确！哦，这太火爆了！好吧。好吧。
In the fire episode, what three books did Angela say she would bring on a desert island? She would bring the Bible. She would bring the Da Vinci Code so she can burn the Da Vinci Code. And she would bring, I just watched this. Oh no, she would bring A Purpose Driven Life. Yes. Yes. All right, two points, Jenna. All right. She would bring a purpose-driven life. Yes! Yes!
在《火灾》那一集里，安吉拉说她去荒岛会带哪三本书？她会带《圣经》。她会带《达·芬奇密码》，这样她就可以烧掉《达·芬奇密码》。她还会带，我刚看过这个。哦不，她会带《标杆人生》（A Purpose Driven Life）。是的。是的。好的，两分，珍娜。好的。她会带《标杆人生》。是的！是的！
All right, two points, Jenna. Very nice. All right, let's see. Last question for this round. It's two for Jenna, one for Cassie. You can do it, Sam. Here we go, here we go. In the Hot Girl episode,
好的，两分，珍娜。太棒了。好，来看看。这一轮的最后一个问题。珍娜两分，卡茜一分。你能行的，萨姆。我们上，我们上。在《辣妹》那一集里，
what product did the vendor Katie want to sell in the conference room? Sam? Nope, that was Cassie. Oh, Cassie! Luxury bags. Handbags. Will we allow it?
供应商凯蒂想在会议室里卖什么产品？萨姆？不对，那是卡茜。哦，卡茜！奢侈品包。手提包。这算对吗？
We allow it. We allow it. Yay. All right. Very good. Current score is Jenna two, Cassie two, me and Sam zero. Well, you didn't get a chance to answer, Anne. I will ask the next round.
算对。算对。耶。太棒了。目前的比分是珍娜两分，卡茜两分，我和萨姆零分。安妮，你刚才没有机会回答。下一轮我来提问。
OK, great. This is fun. Well, let's take a break, because when we come back, we're going to dive into this superfan episode. ["FIZ LOYALTY"] With the FIZ loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff.
好的，太棒了。这太有趣了。好了，我们休息一下，因为回来后我们要深入探讨这个超级粉丝版。［FIZ 忠诚计划］有了 FIZ 忠诚计划，你只要拥有移动套餐就能获得奖励。你知道的，就是为了发短信之类的。
And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with FIZ. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fiz.ca. Time's running out to take advantage of Wealthsimple's best match offer yet. With our big winter bundle, you'll get a 2% match on qualified RRSP transfers and a 1% match on other eligible accounts. Just register and initiate your transfers within 30 days to get your cash bonus. And remember, March 15th is your last chance to make the most of your recent contributions. Minimum $15,000 transfer, additional terms apply. Learn more at Wealthsimple.com slash match. Roll Up to Win is back at Tim Hortons
如果你在使用移动套餐时没有获得诸如额外流量和现金折扣之类的奖励，那你用的就不是 FIZ。今天就转网吧。条件适用，详情请查阅 fiz.ca。Wealthsimple 迄今为止最优惠的匹配活动即将截止。通过我们的冬季大礼包，符合条件的 RRSP 转账可获得 2% 的匹配奖励，其他符合条件的账户可获得 1% 的匹配奖励。只需在 30 天内注册并启动转账，即可获得现金奖励。记住，3 月 15 日是充分利用您近期供款的最后机会。最低转账金额为 15,000 美元，适用其他条款。了解详情请访问 Wealthsimple.com 换杠杆。蒂姆霍顿斯（Tim Hortons）“卷出好运”活动带着数百万奖项回归了
with millions of prizes. Like a vacation with sell off vacations or a tracker off road ATV from Bass Pro Shops. Play on the Tim's app until March 23rd. Rules apply Canada only, no purchase necessary. Visit the Tim's app for details. We are back and the superfan episode for a good little while is pretty much the same. We open on the phone ringing at reception, Pam answers and she forwards a call to Jim's desk.
。比如通过 sell off vacations 提供的假期，或者 Bass Pro Shops 的全地形越野全地形车。在 3 月 23 日之前在 Tim's App 上参与活动。规则适用，仅限加拿大，无需购买。详情请访问 Tim's App。我们回来了，超级粉丝版的开头有一小段时间和原版几乎一模一样。开场是前台电话铃响，帕姆接听并将电话转接给吉姆的办公桌。
It's Katie. It's Katie. Yeah. desk. It's Katie. It's Katie. Yeah and Jim shares they've been out a few times you know that she makes him laugh and he thinks she's cute and then Pam says to Jim you know you can just give her your extension. Yeah. Mm-hmm. She's like I don't want to talk to that bitch anymore. Fan theory that we did not discuss the first time, there is a lot of chatter of people thinking that maybe Jim purposely wanted Katie to call him at work through Pam.
是凯蒂。是凯蒂。对的。桌。是凯蒂。是凯蒂。对，然后吉姆分享说他们已经出去过几次了，你知道的，她总是逗得他哈哈大笑，他觉得她很可爱，然后帕姆对吉姆说，你知道的，你可以直接把你的分机号给她。是的。嗯哼。她的样子就像是：我才不想再跟那个碧池说话了。第一次我们没有讨论过的粉丝理论，有很多人在讨论，觉得也许吉姆是通过帕姆故意让凯蒂打工作电话找他的。
To make Pam jealous? Maybe. Well, when I was looking at the shooting draft, there was a little bit of like a topper to this scene before the phone rings at reception, where Jim was gonna be on the phone with Katie at his desk. On his cell phone? On his cell phone, and he would say,
为了让帕姆嫉妒？也许吧。嗯，当我查看拍摄剧本时，在台前电话铃响之前的这个场景里还有一个小插曲，吉姆原本要在办公桌上给凯蒂打电话。用他的手机？用他的手机，然后他会说，
oh, my battery's dying, call me back at work. And then she calls reception. That got clipped off. So. That would explain why she's not calling his cell phone. Yeah. But is he intentionally doing it? Right. Is he pretending like his cell phone is dying? Because he I don't think so. I don't think he's pretending. I think if anyone in this episode does something a little bit manipulative out of jealousy, it's Pam at the end. We'll get to it. We'll get to it.
哦，我手机没电了，打我工作电话回我。然后她才打到前台。那段被剪掉了。所以。这就解释了为什么她不打他手机了。对。但他是故意的吗？对。他是在假装自己的手机没电了吗？因为我—我不觉得。我不觉得他是装的。我觉得如果这集里有人出于嫉妒做出了一点点操纵性的行为，那就是最后时刻的帕姆。我们待会儿会聊到。我们待会儿会聊到。
Well, now the show starts with a scene with Ryan in Michael's office. And basically what we find out is that Ryan needs an evaluation. He's got like this form, and Michael is not taking it seriously at all. It's for the temp agency, you know? To see how Ryan's doing in his position. Michael says, Howard slash Ryan. Ryan
好，现在节目从迈克尔办公室里瑞安的镜头开始。基本上我们发现瑞安需要进行一次绩效评估。他拿着这样一份表格，而迈克尔一点也没当回事。这是临时工中介要用的，你知道的吧？为了看看瑞安在他这个岗位上表现得怎么样。迈克尔说：霍华德斜杠瑞安。瑞安
Howard is sitting in my office and he has been a temp here for a couple of months and he's kind of gotten the lay of the land a little bit, had a few laughs along the way, and now he wants to know what I think. And Ryan says, the temp agency wants to know what you think. And Michael goes, shall we? Let us proceed. First up, proficiency and necessary skills. And Michael goes, shall we let us proceed? First up, proficiency and necessary skills. And Michael goes, excellent. And then starts laughing. So the scene ends there in the original broadcast. But in the superfan episode, it continues. And Jenna, there's a little bit of Michael mangling phrases for you to add to your list. Ooh, let's hear it. Ha ha ha.
霍华德正坐在我的办公室里，他在这里当临时工已经有几个月了，他基本上已经对这里的情况轻车熟路了，一路上也发生过不少趣事，现在他想知道我的看法。瑞安说：临时工中介想知道你的看法。然后迈克尔说：我们要开始吗？让我们继续。首先，熟练程度和必要技能。然后迈克尔说：我们要开始吗？让我们继续。首先，熟练程度和必要技能。然后迈克尔说：太棒了。接着开始大笑。原版播出时场景就在这里结束了。但在超级粉丝版中，它延续下去了。珍娜，这里有一小段迈克尔乱用词组的片段，可以加进你的清单里。噢，我们听听看。哈哈哈哈。
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha. Thank you. Oh. Bad. I saw the sweat beading. Okay, let's get serious. Work ethic. Not too shabby.
哈哈哈哈哈。谢谢。哦。糟了。我看到汗珠在渗出来了。好了，我们严肃点。职业道德。还算马马虎虎。
Not too shabby. Not too shabby. It's excellent, satisfactory, needs improvement, or not applicable. Or not too shabby. That's right. Well, there's actually a separate place for comments. I know, I know. I'll... Okay.
还算马马虎虎。还算马马虎虎。它是优秀、满意、需要改进，还是不适用。或者叫马马虎虎。没错。其实还有一个专门写评语的地方。我知道，我知道。我……好吧。
At the bottom. Fine. Excellent. Thank you. Excellent. Social integration. That's not applicable. Wow. Social interaction? Probably. Social integration?
在底部。行。优秀。谢谢。优秀。社会融合。那不适用。哇。社会互动？大概吧。社会融合？
Integration? Not whatever Michael said. He also says applicable. Not applicable. And poor Ryan, he wants to just keep writing his own box that says, not too shabby. Oh my gosh. As part of this interview, Michael's going to ask Ryan what he wants to be doing in five years. And Ryan is going to reveal, oh, I
融合？才不是迈克尔说的那个词。他还说“适用”。不适用。可怜的瑞安，他只想一直写他自己的那个选项，上面写着：马马虎虎。天哪。作为这次访谈的一部分，迈克尔要问瑞安他五年后想做什么，而瑞安将透露，哦，我
want to have my own company one day. I want to own my own company. And Michael is like, don't be ridiculous. Yeah. Ryan is like, I'm serious. I'm going to business school. I want to do this. And for whatever reason, Michael now is going to decide that he is going to mentor Ryan. He's going to mentor him to success. Yeah. That is his new goal in life. Yeah. You know, Michael sort of says, I'm kind of like a combo of Mr. Miyagi and Yoda. And then Michael does his impression of Yoda. And we did not discuss this last time.
希望有一天能拥有自己的公司。我想拥有自己的公司。然后迈克尔就像是：别开玩笑了。是的。瑞安说：我是认真的。我在读商学院。我想这么做。不管出于什么原因，迈克尔现在决定要当瑞安的导师。他要引导瑞安走向成功。是的。这是他人生的新目标。是的。你知道，迈克尔有点像说自己是宫城先生（Mr. Miyagi）和尤达大师（Yoda）的结合体。然后迈克尔模仿起了尤达大师。上次我们没有讨论过这个。
And I think it's a decent impression. And I think we should hear it. Okay. Rolled into one. Much advice, you seek. That's pretty good. Much advice, you seek. So this was in the original episode, this impression of Yoda. Much advice, you seek? That's pretty good. Much advice, you seek?
我觉得他模仿得还不错。我觉得我们应该听听看。合二为一。诸多指教，汝欲寻。挺像那么回事的。诸多指教，汝欲寻。所以这在原版剧集里就有，这段对尤达的模仿。诸多指教，汝欲寻？挺像那么回事的。诸多指教，汝欲寻？
So this was in the original episode, this impression of Yoda. But in this rewatch of it, now that we've watched the whole series, it is really taking on a new meaning for me because his Yoda voice is such a miss in bonding with Ryan, but later it is the thing that will lead to love with Holly. Holly! Aww. with Ryan, but later it is the thing that will lead to love with Holly. Aw. So he's had this Yoda voice for all these years. And he just needed the person who appreciated it. Yes. Me and Holly. Yes. Well, in honor of Michael's
所以这在原版剧集里就有，这段对尤达的模仿。但在这次重温中，在我们看完整部剧之后，它对我来说真的有了新的含义，因为他的尤达嗓在和瑞安拉近关系时完全搞砸了，但后来它却成了收获与霍莉的爱情的关键！霍莉！噢。和瑞安，但后来它却成了收获与霍莉的爱情的关键。噢。所以他这些年一直留着这个尤达嗓。他只是在等那个能欣赏它的人。是的。我和霍莉。是的。为了纪念迈克尔的
Yoda voice, I should have told you guys that there is a prize for our quiz. Oh yeah and guess what, it's like you know when like the bag is also a gift so not only what's inside is a gift but also the thing holding the gift is a gift. So humble yeah. Your favorite. One of my favorite things, like I like the basket as much as what's in the basket. Yes. Well in honor of Michael's Yoda. Oh my gosh it's a Star Wars bag and what is in it we don't know. It's a surprise. Okay. Or should I say surprise you I shall. Well when we broke down this episode the first time we were very fixated on the green magic eight ball on Michael's desk, Angela. I know.
尤达嗓，我本来应该告诉你们，我们的问答游戏是有奖品的。哦对，你猜怎么着，就像那种袋子本身也是礼物的情况，所以不仅袋子里的东西是礼物，连装着礼物的那个袋子也是礼物。真朴素啊。你最喜欢的。我最喜欢的东西之一，就像我喜欢篮子胜过喜欢篮子里的东西一样。是的。为了致敬迈克尔的尤达。天哪，这是一个《星球大战》的袋子，里面装的是什么我们还不知道。是个惊喜。或者我应该说：给你惊喜，我将。好吧，当我们第一次剖析这一集时，安吉拉，我们非常迷恋迈克尔桌上那个绿色的魔法八号球。我知道。
We wondered, what is it? Where can you get it? Well, I went back to your amazing Instagram post for the fire, and I looked through all the comments and feedback from fans. Did people know? Yes Yes, dusty are Alec T and Eddie del 14 all commented that that magic eight ball is called the financial advisor The financial advisor magic eight ball has hot tips to put you on the road to financial success. Hot tips?
我们在想，这是什么？在哪能买到？于是我回去看了你在《火灾》那一集里的精彩 Instagram 帖子，我翻看了粉丝们的所有评论和反馈。大家知道吗？知道的，Dusty、Alec T 和 Eddie del 14 都评论说那个魔法八号球叫“金融顾问”。“金融顾问”魔法八号球能为你提供通往财务成功之路的热门秘诀。热门秘诀？
Mm-hmm. Stocks, bonds, commodities, mutual funds, sub IRAs. Confusing? With the financial advisor, sound financial device is always at your fingertips, and it is the answer to all your money troubles. Doesn't it make so much sense, like later we're going to find out that Michael was going to go to business school, but he lost all his money in a pyramid scheme. Isn't this exactly the person who would get financial advice from a green financial advisor ball?
嗯哼。股票、债券、大宗商品、共同基金、次级 IRA。觉得很困惑？有了金融顾问，稳健的财务建议永远触手可及，它就是你所有金钱烦恼的答案。这不是很合理吗，就像我们后来会发现的那样，迈克尔本来打算去读商学院，但他把所有的钱都在传销骗局里输光了。这不正是那个会向一个绿色的金融顾问球寻求理财建议的人吗？
Yes. Yeah, that tracks. Well, while I was Googling green magic eight ball, I found a green magic eight ball necklace. It is this yellow gold orb on a chain. And it looks like a magic eight ball. It is set with diamonds and green enamel. And it is available for $26,800. What?
是的。对，这很符合他的作风。嗯，当我在谷歌上搜索“绿色魔法八号球”时，我发现了一条绿色魔法八号球项链。它是一个挂在链子上的黄金球体。它看起来就像一个魔法八号球。上面镶嵌着钻石和绿色珐琅。售价 26,800 美元。什么？
Yeah. It's pre-order only, though, and it takes about two to three months to be made. It also comes in purple or white. The white one is only $22,480. There you go. So if you are a person who has more money than you know what to do with and you want to buy a Magic 8 ball necklace, we'll put a
是的。不过只能预订，制作大约需要两到三个月。它也有紫色或白色的。白色的只要 22,480 美元。给你。所以，如果你是个钱多得不知该怎么花、又想买一条魔法八号球项链的人，我们会把
Lincoln stories. Well there is a second part to this moment of Yoda where Michael does his impression and he says to Ryan, do you know who that is? And Ryan says, Fozzie Bear. Now we have a Michael talking head that's only in the super fan episode. It's not in the original where Michael says, Fozzie Bear, who could Fozzie Bear possibly mentor? Gonzo, animal, Rolf? Oh, Ryan has a lot to learn.
林肯的故事。嗯，关于迈克尔模仿尤达的这个高潮片段还有第二部分，迈克尔对瑞安说，你知道那是谁吗？瑞安说：阿熊福兹（Fozzie Bear）。现在我们有了一个只在超级粉丝版里出现的迈克尔访谈镜头。原版里没有，迈克尔在里面说：阿熊福兹，阿熊福兹能指导谁？刚onzo、动物（Animal）、洛尔夫（Rolf）？哦，瑞安要学的东西还多着呢。
I was really curious about this talking head. So I found some candy bag alts for these Michael talking heads where he wants to mentor Ryan and I want to read you one because it is so funny. Do you know how much I would have killed to be sitting across from someone like me? The ironic thing is that he envies me. Ryan envies me because I know much more than he does. But I envy Ryan because I know what he's about to know and it's awesome. Freaking awesome. I envy Ryan because I wish I had the chance to learn what I already know for the first time. I love that talking head.
我对这个访谈镜头非常好奇。所以我为迈克尔这些想要指导瑞安的访谈镜头找了一些被删减的糖果袋替代镜头，我想读给你们听一个，因为它太搞笑了。你知道当坐在我面前的是一个像我这样的人时，我会多么兴奋吗？具有讽刺意味的是，他在嫉妒我。瑞安在嫉妒我，因为我知道的比他多得多。但我嫉妒瑞安，因为我知道他即将知道的事情，那太棒了。酷毙了。我嫉妒瑞安，因为我希望自己也有机会第一次学到我已经知道的东西。我太喜欢那个访谈镜头了。
Well, now we're going to have two little slice of life moments that were added to the super fan episode. They're very quiet. They are wonderful. I loved seeing them added back in. The first one is Jim going over to, I couldn't tell, the shredder, some sort of file or something by Pam's reception desk, and he looks over her shoulder and sees the weather report. Yeah, it says 70s and clear. And he goes, that's nice. Where is it?
好，现在我们要迎来两个加进超级粉丝版里的生活切片小片段。它们非常安静。它们太棒了。我很高兴看到它们被加回来。第一个是吉姆走到——我看不清是碎纸机，还是帕姆前台旁边的一些文件之类的地方，他探身越过她的肩膀看天气预报。对，上面写着七十多度，天气晴朗。他说：这挺不错。在哪儿呢？
Yeah, and Pam's like, that's here. He's like, hm. But Pam is not engaging him the way she normally would. Normally, we know that that little thing would lead to some flirty banter. But Pam's got a wall up since the Katie since the Katie phone call. Mm-hmm And then we go over to accounting and Kevin is just he's counting out loud He starts with the number 63. That's where we pick up and when he gets to 69, he just giggles He can't help himself. You can't and it literally is the bane of Angela's existence and you just see her scowling at him
对，然后帕姆说：就在这儿。他说：嗯。但帕姆并没有像往常那样跟他互动。通常我们知道，那个小动作会引发一些调情的玩笑。但自从凯蒂——自从凯蒂打来电话后，帕姆就筑起了一道墙。嗯哼。然后我们转到会计部，凯文正在大声数数。他从数字 63 开始。我们从这里切入，当他数到 69 时，他只是咯咯地笑了起来。他控制不住自己。你根本控制不住，这简直是安吉拉的眼中钉，你可以看到她在对翻白眼。
But that's it. And I loved these. They don't really further the plot, but they're the little office slice of life that we had to cut out when we could only make a 21 minute episode, but that the super fan gets to breathe and enjoy. So I loved those.
但就是这样。我太喜欢这些了。它们并没有真正推动剧情发展，但它们是办公室生活的小切片，当我们只能剪出一集 21 分钟的剧集时，它们不得不被删减，但在超级粉丝版里，它们得以呼吸和享受。所以我太喜欢这些了。
Me too. Well, now Michael is going to outline the 10 rules of business for Ryan. And he can only come up with one on the spot. Why does he do this to himself? He's made this big statement that he's going to share this wisdom with Ryan, and then he stresses out the rest of the day because he can only think of one. Then he says, you know what, Ryan, I'll tell you the rest after lunch.
我也是。好吧，现在迈克尔要为瑞安总结商业十诫。但他当场只能想出一条。他为什么总要这么折磨自己？他刚信誓旦旦地说要把这些智慧传授给瑞安，结果接下来一整天都在为此焦虑，因为他只能想出一条。然后他说：你知道吗，瑞安，午饭后我再告诉你剩下的。
Yes. Well, the one piece of advice he has so far is you have to play to win, but you have to win to play. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Chew on that. Chew on that. You have to win to play?
是的。嗯，他目前唯一的建议就是：你必须为了赢而玩，但你必须为了玩而赢。对。对。对。好好琢磨琢磨这个。好好琢磨琢磨。你必须为了玩而赢？
I know. How's that work? Now we're going to have a Dwight talking head and we should mention that this whole time Dwight has been clocking all of his attention that Michael is giving Ryan Oh, yeah is getting jealous. He's really bummed out. He's wanted to be evaluated by Michael for years Yes, and he says his relationship with Michael is special. It's like Batman and Robin the Lone Ranger and Tonto It's not like there was some third guy named Bonto, right? This third guy this third wheel is really a thorn in his side. I know.
我知道。这怎么说得通？现在我们要看一个德怀特的访谈镜头，我们应该提一下，这段时间德怀特一直在留意迈克尔对瑞安的所有关注。哦，对，他开始嫉妒了。他真的很沮丧。他一直想让迈克尔对他进行评估，已经盼了好几年了。是的，他说他和迈克尔的关系很特殊。就像蝙蝠侠和罗宾、独行侠和托ント（Tonto）。又不是有什么第三个人叫邦托（Bonto），对吧？这个第三者、电灯泡真的是他的心头大患。我知道。
So Dwight is going to approach Ryan in the kitchen and try to bond with him. He is. And this is where I would like to give Dwight a Dundee for Crappiest at Small Talk. I really think we should hear it. You know what you would love? Guns and roses. When I was your age, I loved guns and roses. Do you like guns and roses? I'll make you a tape. I'll make you two tapes. I don't have a tape player. Someday, Temp. I've got a couple of shirts that don't fit so well anymore. I'll bring them by.
所以德怀特要在厨房里接近瑞安，并试图和他套近乎。他确实这么做了。在这里，我要给德怀特颁发一个“最逊闲聊奖”的邓迪奖。我觉得我们真的应该听听看。你知道你会喜欢什么吗？枪炮与玫瑰乐队（Guns N' Roses）。我像你这么大的时候，超爱枪炮与玫瑰。你喜欢枪炮与玫瑰吗？我给你录一盘磁带。我给你录两盘磁带。我没有磁带播放机。总有一天会有的，临时工。我有几件衬衫不太合身了。我带给你。
Okay. Okay, I have to give people a visual to go along with this because this is a super fan scene and the way Rain as Dwight is standing is so amazing. He's kind of cornered Ryan up against the kitchen counter. Like- Yeah, like Ryan has some business at the counter but then Dwight's like looming behind him.
好吧。好吧，我得给大家提供一个视觉画面来配合这个，因为这是一个超级粉丝版里的场景，雷恩（Rain）饰演的德怀特站的那个姿势太绝了。他基本上把瑞安逼到了厨房操作台的角落里。就像——对，就像瑞安本来要在台子那里办点事，然后德怀特就庞大地笼罩在他身后。
He's really in his personal space. He's close talking. Ryan can only turn around, and then he can't turn back around because his space has been made so small for this conversation. That was my favorite part of the scene, was just the spatial relationship between these two actors and the way you can just see Ryan kind of dying
他真的侵入了别人的私人空间。他在贴面私语。瑞安只能转过身去，然后又无法转回来，因为在这个对话中，他的空间被挤得太小了。那是这一幕里我最喜欢的部门，就是这两个演员之间的空间关系，以及你能看出瑞安在这场对话中内心那种慢慢死去的痛苦。我最喜欢的部分还是最后拍背的那一下。他说：我有旧衬衫。我给你带几件来。然后他拍了拍，但有点犹豫，就像是拍、拍、拍、拍。太尴尬了。
a slow death inside during this conversation. My favorite part of it was also the pat on the back at the end. He's like, I have old shirts. I'll bring you some. And then he's like, he does this pat, but sort of like hesitantly, like pat, pat, pat, pat. Like, so awkward.
太尴尬了。太尴尬了。好，现在我们回到迈克尔的办公室。德怀特也在里面，因为迈克尔必须想出那全部十条规则。所以他请求德怀特帮他。对，然后德怀特说：好啊，我们来吧。不过德怀特想出来的版本总是有点太过了。好吧，从这个智囊团里我们得到了两条规则。
So awkward. So awkward. So now we go back to Michael's office. Dwight is in there with him because Michael has to come up with all these 10 rules. So he's asked Dwight to help him. Yeah, and Dwight is like, yeah, let's do it. Except that Dwight's version are always like a bit too much. Well, here are the two rules we get out of this think tank.
这就是你们的宝贝。顺便说一句，第三条规则，我们跳过了第二条。第三条规则是：仰望星空。如果失败了，参见第四条。第四条规则是：失败不是选项。这就是我们所有的了。然后德怀特说：然后到最后，你会向大家透露它们其实都是同一条规则。
Here are your gems. Rule three, by the way rules we get out of this think tank. Here are your gems. Rule three, by the way, we've skipped rule two. Rule three is reach for the stars. If you fail, see rule four. And rule four is failure is not an option. That's all we have. And then Dwight's like, and then at the end, you will reveal that they were all one rule.
然后迈克尔说：不，德怀特，我不是想捉弄他。我是真的想给他提供有用的信息。是的。接着德怀特说：也许你需要申请延期。这真的把我逗笑了。迈克尔说：我才不会向他申请延期，除非我真的需要。
And Michael's like, no, Dwight, I'm not trying to trick him. I actually want to give him helpful information. Yes. And then Dwight is like, maybe you need to ask for an extension. That really made me laugh. Michael's like, I'm not going to ask him for an extension unless I really need it.
这真的把我逗笑了。一想到要跑去跟临时工说“能把给你的商业规则截止日期延期吗”，就觉得好笑。然后在超级粉丝版里，有一个新的德怀特访谈镜头，你能看出他对瑞安实在是不满。他说：你知道，我和迈克尔有一种特殊的联系，有点像脐带。他真的不想看到瑞安被这根脐带绊倒，或者被它缠住脖子。好，现在火警警报响了。安吉拉和德怀特立刻行动起来。我们
That really made me laugh. Just the thought of going to the temp and saying, can I get an extension on my rules of business for you? And then in the superfan episode, there is a new Dwight talking head, and you can just tell he is just not happy about Ryan. He says, you know, Michael and I have a special connection, kind of like an umbilical cord. And he really doesn't want to see Ryan get tripped up in the umbilical cord or maybe with it caught around his neck. Well now the fire alarm goes off. Angela and Dwight go into action. We
上次讨论过这个。珍娜，当我们第一次剖析这一集时，你问我在这场戏里有没有即兴发挥，我挺确信我即兴说了“双臂贴紧身体”，因为说出这种话太荒谬了。但我们当时没有拍摄剧本，所以我无法双重确认。好吧，现在我们有了，我能够去核实一下。确实，我即兴发挥了“双臂贴紧身体”和“你的安全伙伴”。
talked about this last time. Jenna when we first broke down this episode you asked me if I had improvised anything during the scene and I was pretty sure I had improvised Arms at Your Side because that's such a ridiculous thing to say. But we didn't have the shooting draft, so I couldn't double check that. Well, now we do, and I was able to go and check it. And I did, I improvised arms at your side and your safety partner.
这些是我在这场戏里的大即兴发挥。在疏散过程中，迈克尔会推开所有人，迅速逃跑。他是第一个冲出门的人。好吧，他是船长嘛。是的，他有一个访谈镜头，在里面解释了为什么他必须成为第一个逃出来的人，
Those were my big improv moments in this scene. During the evacuation, Michael is going to push ahead of everyone and flee very quickly. He's the first one out the door. Well, he's the captain of the ship. Yes, he has a talking head where he explains why he needed to be the first one out,
我觉得我们应该听听看。是的，我是第一个逃出来的。船长永远是船上第一个上船、最后一个离船的人。而这个停车场就是我们的船，当大楼着火的时候。所以我跑到了船上，是的，我听过“妇孺优先”，但我们不雇佣儿童。幸好我们不是血汗工厂。而且法律规定妇女在职场上是平等的。所以我让他们先出去了。我手里可有一场官司要打呢。好吧。还有呢？这个时刻让我想起了一部叫作《游客》（Force Majeure）的电影。你们
and I think we should hear it. Yes, I was the first one out. A captain is always the first one on the ship and the last one off the ship. always the first one on the ship and the last one off the ship. And this parking lot is our ship when the building is on fire. So I ran out onto the ship and yes I've heard women and children first but we do not employ children. We are not a sweat shop, thankfully. And women are equal in the workplace by law. So I let them out first. I have a lawsuit on my hands. Okay. And? Yeah. This moment made me think of this movie called Force Major. Have you
看过吗？卡茜、萨姆，你们看过《游客》吗？我没看过。没，没听说过。好吧，我非常激动地极力推荐。这是一部由鲁本·奥斯特伦德（Ruben Östlund）编剧和执导的电影。它讲的是一个家庭的故事，这是一部外国电影，有法语、瑞典语和英语。
seen it? Cassie, Sam, have you seen Force Major? I have not. No, haven't heard of it. Okay, very excited to highly recommend. This is a movie that was written and directed by Ruben Ausland. It is about a family, it's a foreign film, it's in French and Swedish and English.
这个家庭在法国阿尔卑斯山滑雪，他们在吃午饭。他们有点坐在滑雪胜地的露台上，突然听到附近的山上发出“轰”的一声巨响。雪崩。雪崩。你看到雪从山上滚落下来，正朝着他们坐着的这个露台席卷而来。爸爸站起来逃跑了。他就是迈克尔。他跑进室内寻求安全。妈妈只有时间把自己的身体压在两个孩子身上。他们被雪覆盖了。太可怕了。最后大家都安然无恙。没有人受伤。但她说：你抛弃了我们！是的！整部电影剩下的部分就是这个女人意识到她的丈夫和伴侣
This family is skiing in the French Alps and they're at lunch. They're kind of on the patio at their ski resort when all of a sudden you hear this big boom on the mountain sort of nearby. Avalanche. Avalanche. You see the snow coming down the hill and it's coming toward this outdoor patio that they're seated at. The dad gets up and flees. He's Michael. He runs indoors to safety. The mom only has time to like throw her body over her two kids. They get covered in snow. It's terrifying. In the end everyone is fine. No one gets hurt. But she's like, you left us! Yes! The whole rest of the movie is just the aftermath of the fact that this woman is realizing that her husband and partner
在紧急关头逃跑了之后的余波。这太棒了。它获得了金球奖最佳外语片提名。他们还拍了一部美国翻拍版，由威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）和朱莉娅·路易斯-德利法斯（Julia Louis-Dreyfus）主演，名叫《风暴佳人》（Downhill）。我们实际上跟威尔聊过拍摄他的版本的事。重制版《风暴佳人》比原版更有喜剧色彩，但这是我最喜欢的电影之一。
fled during an emergency. It is amazing. It was nominated for best foreign language film at the Golden Globes. They did an American remake with Will Ferrell and Julia Louis-Dreyfus called Downhill. We actually talked with Will about filming his version. Downhill is more comedic than the original, but this is one of my favorite movies.
太引人入胜了。太引人入胜了。太引人入胜了。这不是一个很好的故事切入点吗？对。就像爸爸只是像平时一样，他们根本不谈论发生了什么。那天晚上他们叫了一些朋友过来。他们喝了好多酒。
It is riveting. It is riveting. It is riveting. Isn't that such a good in for a story? Yeah. Like the dad is just like going on as it's like, they're not talking about what happened. That evening they have some friends come over. They have a bunch of wine.
然后这个女人醉醺醺地把这个故事讲了出来。她说：我有个故事讲给你们听。然后所有人都一脸懵：什么鬼？一切都真相大白了。太精彩了。大家，请务必欣赏《游客》。但这就是那个访谈镜头让我想到的。是的，因为他早就溜之大吉了。
And then the woman drunkenly tells the story. She's like, I've got a story for you. And everyone is like, what the hell? It all unravels. It's delicious. Everyone, please enjoy force majeure. But that's what that talking head made me think of. Yes, because he's out of there.
他早就溜之大吉了。好，现在所有人都撤离了大楼。而这一集剩下的部分将全部在停车场进行。迈克尔将继续指导瑞安，他想出了他的下一条商业规则。是的。他不确定瑞安有没有在听他讲话，而 BJ 的台词念得简直绝了。
He's out of there. Well, now everyone has exited the building. And the rest of this episode is going to be in the parking lot this episode is going to be in the parking lot. Michael is going to continue to mentor Ryan and he's got his next rule of business. Yes. He's not sure Ryan's listening to him and BJ has the best line read ever.
他说：你有没有在听我说话，瑞安？我刚才说什么了？我刚才说什么了？然后 BJ 饰演的瑞安说：对，我懂了。适应、反应、再适应、切题。切题。我不知道那是什么。但那其实是第二条规则。
He's like, are you listening to me, Ryan? What did I say? What did I say? And BJ, as Ryan says, yeah, I got it. Adapt, react, readapt, apt. Apt. I'm not sure what that is. But that is actually rule number two.
所以我们又回到第二条规则了。德怀特跑出了大楼。他要求清点人数。他来到迈克尔和瑞安面前。他说：迈克尔，你是第一名。他绝不允许瑞安成为第二名。然后德怀特又说了别的话，但我想让我们听听看。
So we're back to rule two now. Dwight is going to run out of the building. He's demanding a head count. He comes up to Michael and Ryan. He's like, Michael, you're number one. He will not let Ryan be number two. And then Dwight says something else, but I want us to hear it.
所以我们现在回到了第二条规则。德怀特跑出了大楼。他要求清点人数。他走到迈克尔和瑞恩面前。他说，迈克尔，你是第一名。他绝不让瑞恩当第二名。然后德怀特又说了别的话，但我希望我们听听看。
Let's listen. So what was rule two? Adapt, react, readapt, apt. Okay, well let's just kind of take it a little slower. Hey, Michael, Ryan needs a number for the count off. Okay, well one is taken. Okay, at two? No!
听着。那么第二条规则是什么？适应、反应、再适应、适应。好吧，我们稍微放慢一点节奏。嘿，迈克尔，瑞安需要一个报数号码。好吧，1被占了。好吧，那2呢？不！
Okay, sorry? Okay, he can have 14. Marjor Okay, he can have 14 Marjorie's not here today Marjorie is not here. Who the hell is Marjorie? Who the hell is Marjorie? I wondered if this was an improv, but it's not it's in the script Oh, yeah, is Marjorie the name we gave to Luanne our stand-in our female stand-in that we had For all of season one, and I don't know if she was even there for season two. Is that who Marjorie is? Because she was in fact not in the parking lot, but Devon is in the parking lot, Creed is in the parking lot,
好吧，抱歉？好吧，他可以选14。玛乔——好吧，他可以选14。玛乔丽今天没来。玛乔丽没来。到底谁是玛乔丽？到底谁是玛乔丽？我一开始以为这是即兴发挥，但并不是，剧本里就是这么写的。哦，对，玛乔丽是我们给露安取的名字，她是我们的替身，我们的女性替身。第一季的时候她一直在，我不知道第二季她还在不在。玛乔丽就是她吗？因为她其实不在停车场，但戴夫在停车场，克里德在停车场，
and we're not gonna really learn who Devon and Creed are until the Halloween episode. So I'm pretty sure we called Luan Luan. I thought we called Luan Luan as well. But who is Marjorie? Who's Marjorie? Where did she work? I don't know. Well now Dwight is gonna say maybe him and Michael and Ryan are like the three Musketeers and Michael's like are the three Stooges and this is my favorite Ryan talking head. I just love it.
直到万圣节那一集，我们才知道戴夫和克里德是谁。所以我很确定我们把露安叫成了露安。我以为我们也把露安叫成了露安。但玛乔丽是谁？玛乔丽是谁？她在哪里工作？我不知道。现在德怀特要说，也许他和迈克尔以及瑞安就像三个火枪手，而迈克尔则说那是三个臭皮匠，这是我最喜欢的瑞安单人访谈。我真是太喜欢了。
I thought BJ was so good in this episode. He says, I don't wanna be like a guy here, you know? Like Stanley is the crossword puzzle guy and Angela has cats. I don't wanna have a thing here. You know, I don't wanna be the something guy. That's how little he wants to attach to this place. Please do not give me a nickname.
我觉得BJ在这集里表现得太棒了。他说，你知道的，我不想成为这里某种特定的人。比如斯坦利是填字游戏男，安吉拉有猫。我不想在这里有个什么标签。你知道的，我不想成为那个什么什么男。这就是他多么不想跟这个地方产生羁绊。请不要给我起外号。
Do not try to be my buddy. I am not going to be here long. He does not want an identity here. No. Well, now Jim is going to gather everyone for a very important announcement. This is when he suggests that we play some games. Desert Island, who would you do?
不要试图做我的哥们。我不会在这里待很久的。他不想在这里建立身份认同。不。好吧，现在吉姆要把大家召集起来宣布一件非常重要的事情。这就是他建议我们玩一些游戏的时候。荒岛求生，你会选谁？
And Pam's suggestion of would you rather that we never some games? Desert Island? Who would you do? And Pam's suggestion of would you rather that we never get to. Well I think that is a perfect time to have our second round of office trivia. Get your buzzers ready. Hand me the cards. You're asking the teapot questions Jenna. Am I? Maybe I am. I'm doing whatever I want because I'm the questioner. I thought that was what we agreed to is seasons one through three. No you said that. Thank you Sam. What the hell? Is this what playing games is like with you guys? You just change the rules as you go? So these cards are really cute by the way. So there's the teapot questions, the world's best boss mug questions,
帕姆建议的“你愿意”……我们永远不玩游戏？荒岛求生？你会选谁？而帕姆建议的“你愿意”……我们永远不会去。好吧，我觉得这是进行第二轮办公室冷知识问答的最佳时机。准备好抢答器。把卡片给我。你在问茶壶的问题，珍娜。是吗？也许吧。我想问什么就问什么，因为我是出题人。我以为我们说好的是第一季到第三季的内容。不，那是你说的。谢谢萨姆。搞什么鬼？你们玩游戏都是这样的吗？随玩随改规则？顺便说一句，这些卡片真的很可爱。这里有茶壶的问题，世界最佳老板马克杯的问题，
the pretzels, the beats, and then the fun orb. The multicolored ball that expands and goes back down close. That was on Michael's desk. I actually think it would be fun if we did a different category each round, so I'm gonna ask from the world's best boss questions. Okay, well good lord. These are, I guess, later seasons, seasons four and five. Okay. Ready? Mm-hmm. Okay. These are I guess later seasons. Seasons four and five. Okay.
还有蝴蝶结面包、甜菜，以及那个神奇的弹力球。那个可以膨胀又缩小的多色球。它以前在迈克尔的桌上。其实我觉得如果每轮换一个不同的分类会很有趣，所以我打算从“世界最佳老板”的问题里出题。好吧，天哪。这些，我猜是后面的几季，第四季和第五季。好吧。准备好了吗？嗯。好吧。这些我猜是后面的几季。第四季和第五季。好吧。
Ready? Mm-hmm. In the money episode, what is Michael's second job? Angela. He works at a telemarketing company. Yes. All right. In the chair model episode, who did Pam set Michael up with? Yes, Sam? Her landlord or landlady? Yes, her landlady. Do you know her name? Bonus point if you know her name.
准备好了吗？嗯。《金钱》那一集里，迈克尔的第二份工作是什么？安吉拉。他在一家电话营销公司上班。答对了。好。在《人体模型》那一集里，帕姆给迈克尔撮合的对象是谁？是的，萨姆？她的房东或女房东？是的，她的女房东。你知道她的名字吗？如果你知道她的名字有加分。
Angela? Diane. Nope. Anyone? Susan? It's just a guess in the dark. Margaret. Oh, Margaret.
安吉拉？黛安。不对。有人知道吗？苏珊？只是瞎猜一个。玛格丽特。哦，玛格丽特。
That's all right. You still get a point, Sam. Margaret. Oh Margaret. That's alright you still get a point Sam. Okay. Alright. In the Survivor Man episode what bad idea did Jim have to celebrate birthday month? Angela? That they all combine all their birthdays. Into one party. Yeah. It's Angela. Yes very good. Final question in the Business Trip episode what was the name of the concierge Michael hooked up with in Canada? Oh, shoot.
没关系。你还是得了一分，萨姆。玛格丽特。哦，玛格丽特。没关系，你还是得了一分，萨姆。好吧。好吧。《求生专家》那一集里，吉姆为了庆祝生日月想出了什么糟糕的主意？安吉拉？他们把所有人的生日合并在一起。办一个派对。是的。是安吉拉。回答正确，非常好。最后一题，在《商务旅行》那一集里，迈克尔在加拿大搭讪的前台叫什么名字？哦，该死。
Played by Wendy. Oh, Cassie. Marie Zim. Yes. Cassie, you are on the board with three. You are leading. I have two points. You have two points.
由温迪扮演。哦，卡西。玛丽·齐姆。是的。卡西，你积了三分，上榜了。你现在领先。我有两分。你有两分。
I have two points. Sam, you have one. All right. Very, very good, everyone. Nice round. Yeah, it was a good round. You're changing the rules, but OK. Guess that's how it goes.
我有两分。萨姆，你有一分。好了，大家表现得非常非常棒。不错的一轮。是的，这一轮挺好的。你们在改规则，不过好吧。我想事情就是这样的。
Well, now the fire truck is going to arrive. I don't think anyone's more excited than Dwight. He like fist pumps in the air. He's very excited. In our original breakdown, we had reached out to costume designer Kerry Bennett, who shared about how she recreated the Scranton patches on the firefighters uniforms. Very authentic. Well, this time when I reached out to Kent Zbornak, aka Kentopedia, he was able to tell me a little bit about how we got the fire trucks. He said we rented them.
好了，现在消防车要到了。我觉得没有人比德怀特更兴奋了。他在空中挥拳。他非常兴奋。在我们最初的梳理中，我们联系了服装设计师凯瑞·贝内特，她分享了她是如何复刻消防员制服上的斯克兰顿徽章的。非常逼真。好吧，这次我联系了肯·兹博纳克，也就是“肯百科”，他向我透露了一些我们是如何搞到消防车的细节。他说我们是租来的。
Oh. They cost $5,000. For each one? I think total. Oh. I also asked him if there were any issues with standards and practices for this episode. I mean, considering that we're about to get into all these games. Mm-hmm.
哦。它们要花5000美元。每辆吗？我估计是总共。哦。我还问他这一集在审查标准和规范方面有没有什么问题。我的意思是，考虑到我们马上就要玩所有这些游戏了。嗯。
He said no. He said they didn't have any notes on the games. They just didn't like Randy Cortran. They were fine with Kit Sepornak and Steve Burgess. Wow, you're right. Oh, Kent said they had one note and their one note was to be sure not to glorify fire in the episode, which is good. Yes, that makes sense. So now we're gonna have three all new talking heads. We've got one from Dwight, we've got one from Angela,
他说没有。他说他们对这些游戏没有任何意见。他们只是不喜欢兰迪·科特兰。他们对肯·塞波纳克和史蒂夫·伯吉斯很满意。哇，你说得对。哦，肯说他们只有一个意见，他们的唯一意见是确保这一集里不要美化火灾，这挺好的。是的，这说得通。所以现在我们要有三个全新的单人访谈。我们有一个德怀特的，我们有一个安吉拉的，
and we've got Jim and Pam. Yep. Angela, you break down crying in your talking head. I did. This is completely scripted. My character says, yes, there's a real fire, but it's okay. Everyone got out fine. This is why you practice these things.
还有吉姆和帕姆的。对。安吉拉，你在单人访谈里崩溃大哭了。我确实哭了。这是完全按剧本演的。我的角色说，是的，确实有火灾，但没关系。大家都安全逃出去了。这就是为什么要进行这些演练的原因。
And she starts to cry. It's like the stress has gotten to her. She got us out of the building. She did her job and now she's broken. Yes. Dwight is just all excited. He says he's a safety officer and a volunteer sheriff's deputy.
然后她开始哭泣。这感觉就像压力把她压垮了。她把我们带出了大楼。她完成了她的工作，现在她崩溃了。是的。德怀特兴奋得不行。他说他是安全员兼志愿警长。
I mean, he has been training for this his whole life. Yeah, he said there could be fire inside the walls right now. Jim and Pam are gonna have a dual talking head where Pam says she likes fire drills because they kind of remind her of when you would have class outside in school when there were fire drills in school.
我的意思是，他一辈子都在为这事做准备。对，他说现在墙壁里面可能就有火。吉姆和帕姆将有一个双人单人访谈，帕姆在里面说她喜欢消防演习，因为这有点让她想起上学时遇到消防演习会在室外上课的情景。
Jim has fond memories as well. Yeah, Jim says, we had classes outside all the time and we never did anything. Actually, if I had fewer outside classes, I probably wouldn't be stuck here at a paper company. And then Pam looks at him and goes, you're not stuck, and he smiles. They're having a nice moment here.
吉姆也有美好的回忆。对，吉姆说，我们以前经常在室外上课，而且什么都不用做。其实，如果我在室外的课少一些，我可能就不会被困在一家纸业公司了。然后帕姆看着他说道：“你没有被困住，”他笑了。他们在这里度过了一个美好的时刻。
She's softening to him a little. They are. While this was the fourth episode to air in season two. This was the first one that we recorded when we came back from our break. Yeah. We were all reunited here and they sent a photographer to take pictures. And this photographer took so many pictures of John and I doing this talking head. And it was always so funny to me because the talking heads got cut out of the episode.
她对他态度有点软化了。确实如此。虽然这是第二季播出的第四集，但这却是我们假期结束回来后录制的第一集。对。我们所有人都在这里重聚了，他们还派了一位摄影师来拍照。这位摄影师给我们俩做这个单人访谈拍了好多照片。我一直觉得这挺搞笑的，因为单人访谈在正片里被剪掉了。
But there's all these pictures of you two. All these pictures of us next to this fire truck doing these talking heads. So now these photos make sense because these talking heads have been added back to the super fan episode. Well, I wanted to share two things that Ken Quapus said to me
但有所有你们俩的照片。所有我们站在消防车旁边做这些单人访谈的照片。所以现在这些照片说得通了，因为这些单人访谈已经被重新加回了超级粉丝版里。好吧，我想分享肯·夸普斯对我说过的两件事。
about doing these parking lot scenes. All right. He said, and I quote, the most significant thing that he remembers about this episode was the heat. He said he spent every day thinking he was going to faint. Oh my gosh. He said it was the most physically taxing episode that he directed and he also directed booze cruise mind you He also said that it was very challenging spatially
关于拍摄这些停车场场景。好的。他说，原话是，他关于这一集记忆最深刻的事情就是天气太热了。他说他每天都觉得自己快要晕倒了。哦天哪。他说这是他执导过体能消耗最大的一集，而且请注意，他还执导过《酒后巡航》。他还说空间调度极具挑战性。
He said for him it was like the flip side of the coin to diversity day Diversity day it was like how do I do this whole episode confined in the small room? Mm-hmm and then this episode was how do I do this episode and establish relationships and intimacy in a huge wide parking lot? He said when he directs, he's always trying to find those relationship moments.
他说对他来说，这就像是《多元化日》硬币的反面。《多元化日》就像是，我该如何把整集都局限在一个小房间里拍好？嗯。然后这一集就是，我该如何在巨大空旷的停车场里拍摄并建立人际关系和亲密感？他说当他执导时，他总是在寻找那些展现关系的时刻。
He's always trying to find the family, to establish family. I love that. I did too, but it's really challenging when people are very spread apart. So I just love that. I did too, but it's really challenging when people are very spread apart. So I just love that. But yeah, we talked a good bit of our phone conversation was just about how hot it was. And he said, in the end, I was glad no one collapsed. I'm surprised that, you know, I think of the crew who, in addition to being out in that parking lot with us, were also
他总是在寻找家的感觉，建立家庭感。我太喜欢了。我也是，但当大家离得很分散时，这真的很有挑战性。所以我就是很喜欢。我也是，但当大家离得很分散时，这真的很有挑战性。所以我就是很喜欢。不过是的，我们电话交谈的很大一部分内容都是关于天气有多热。他说，最后，我很高兴没有人晕倒。我很惊讶，你知道的，我想象着剧组人员，除了跟我们一起待在那个停车场里，还要
carrying and holding so much heavy equipment all day. Yeah. And Ken was like, you know, Ange, it was record-breaking heat wave. And I was like, oh, no, it was triple digits. We talked about that. But as we were talking, Jenna, I remembered this thing that I did not remember the first time. And when I rewatched it, I couldn't believe we didn't comment on it.
一整天都在搬运和拿着那么重的器材。对。然后肯就说，你知道的，安吉，那是破纪录的热浪。然后我就说，哦，天哪，那是三位数的高温。我们聊过这个。但正当我们聊着的时候，珍娜，我想起了一件我一开始完全不记得的事。当我重新看这一集时，我简直不敢相信我们居然没有对此发表评论。
You know, if you watch Dwight in any of his scenes, you see a full white t-shirt hanging out from his short sleeve button down. You see his white t-shirt sleeve. And it was because he was sweating so much that he had to wear that shirt because he was pitting out his mustard shirt. So they were layering the guys so they wouldn't sweat through their shirts.
你知道的，如果你注意看德怀特的任何一个镜头，你会发现他短袖衬衫里面露出一件厚厚的白T恤。你能看到他的白T恤袖子。这是因为他流汗太多了，以至于他不得不穿那件衬衫，因为他的芥末黄衬衫都被汗湿透了。所以他们让男演员们叠穿衣服，这样他们的衬衫就不会被汗透了。
So crazy. Well, and when I was trading messages with Kent, he also mentioned the heat. He said this, quote, Because we filmed this episode the first week of a hot August and a lot of our filming was outside in the parking lot, I made the decision to silk the exterior parking lot from the rooftop to the sidewalk so we could keep a little cooler. Remember those?
太疯狂了。好吧，当我跟肯发信息交流时，他也提到了炎热。他是这么说的，原话是：“因为我们在八月酷暑的第一周拍摄这一集，而且我们的很多镜头都是在室外的停车场拍的，所以我决定用丝绸从屋顶一直铺到人行道，把室外的停车场遮起来，这样我们可以凉快一点。还记得那些吗？”
Yeah, wasn't it just like a giant tarp? It's like a very thin, white silk. Silky, silky, scrim tarp thing. Yeah, yeah. And it's meant to kind of just diffuse the sunlight. So it's not, I don't think it's SPF or anything, but it does like cut the heat. It's almost like in your house if you drew like a sheer curtain to cut the sun. Well Kent said, quote,
对，那不就像是一块巨大的防水布吗？就像是一种非常薄的白丝绸。丝滑的、薄纱状的遮阳篷。对，对。它的作用就是为了扩散阳光。所以它不具备防晒指数什么的，但它确实能隔热。这几乎就像你在家里拉上一层薄窗帘来挡太阳一样。好吧，肯说，原话是：
I kind of regretted that decision because you can see those silks in some of the shots. And they were noisy as they flapped in the breeze. Now, I did not notice them when I was rewatching this episode, but I think it's funny that after all these years, he is still annoyed. He still remembers. He's like, oh, those silk, those silks. I also thought this is when I think the fact that both Randall Einhorn and Matt Sohn had been camera operators on Survivor,
“我有点后悔那个决定，因为你在一些镜头里能看到那些丝绸。而且它们在微风中 flapping（扑扇）时会有噪音。”现在，我重看这一集时并没有注意到它们，但我觉得很有趣的是，过了这么多年，他居然还是觉得很烦恼。他居然还记得。他就像是，哦，那些丝绸，那些丝绸。我还觉得，雷德利·爱因霍恩和马特·索恩都曾在《幸存者》中担任过摄像师，
I feel like that really paid off. Really came in handy, because I know they did some pretty grueling things, you know, in those seasons of Survivor when people are like hiking through wilderness. Yeah, there's, you know, Randall and Matt were hiking alongside of them filming it all. Well, now Jim is going to ask everyone which three books they would take on a desert island. We've already covered what Angela is taking in our quiz. Well, I really loved Dwight's pick so much.
我觉得这真的发挥了巨大作用。真的派上了大用场，因为我知道他们在《幸存者》那些人们跋涉穿过荒野的赛季里，做过一些相当折磨人的事情。对，你知道的，雷德利和马特是一路跟在他们旁边边走边拍的。好了，现在吉姆要问大家会带哪三本书去荒岛。我们在测验里已经讨论过安吉拉会带什么了。好吧，我真的很喜欢德怀特的选书。
I feel like we need to hear it. Fine. Physicians desk reference. Nice. Hollowed out inside waterproof matches, iodine tablets, beat seeds, protein bars, NASA blanket, and in case I get bored, Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone. No, Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban. Question, did my shoes come off in the plane crash? Amazing. Amazing. He's speaking to me. I know he is. Physician's Desk reference,
我觉得我们必须要听听。好吧。医师案头参考书。不错。里面掏空了，塞进防水火柴、碘片、甜菜种子、蛋白棒、NASA保温毯，如果我无聊的话，还有《哈利·波特与魔法石》。不对，《哈利·波特与阿兹卡班的囚徒》。请问，飞机失事的时候我的鞋子飞出去了吗？太棒了。太棒了。他简直说出了我的心声。我知道是的。医师案头参考书，
such a smart answer. I wouldn't hollow it out. I wouldn't hollow it out either. But you know, the scene is a little bit longer in the super fan episode. Right after Dwight says, did my shoes come off in the plane crash? He goes on to say, this is important. Leather is a food source. Leather from shoes can be boiled down to a simple broth
多聪明的答案。我要是才不会把它掏空呢。我也不会把它掏空。但你知道，在超级粉丝版里，这个场景稍微长了一点。就在德怀特问完“飞机失事的时候我的鞋子飞出去了吗”之后，他接着说道：“这很重要。皮革是一种食物来源。鞋子上的皮革可以熬成简单的肉汤，
that can sustain a man for over two weeks. Well lady, I had to know. Is this one of those things that Dwight is half-fried about? Oh my God, tell me. I need to know. Okay. My survivalist brain needs to know the answer. Can I drink the broth of my boiled shoe?
能维持一个男人两周以上的生命。”好吧，天哪，我必须知道。这是不是那种德怀特半信半疑的事情之一？哦，天哪，快告诉我。我必须知道。好吧。我的求生本能迫切想知道答案。我能喝煮鞋子的汤吗？
Well? Will it sustain me? Well, here's the thing, lady. The quick answer is no. You should not eat leather from shoes. Because while technically leather contains some protein, most commercially tanned leather used in shoes is treated with chemicals and dyes making it unsafe to consume and eating it can cause digestive issues. Sure,
好吧？它能维持我的生命吗？好吧，事情是这样的，姑娘。简短的回答是：不能。你不应该吃鞋子上的皮革。因为虽然严格来说皮革含有一些蛋白质，但鞋子里绝大多数商业鞣制的皮革都经过化学物质和染料的处理，这使得它不适合食用，食用它会导致消化问题。当然，
eating it raw. Eating it raw, yes, but what if I boil it? It's still going to be boiled in its chemicals. I guess that's true. Don't we, remember in like old cartoons, you would see the cartoon characters boil their shoe? Well, here's what I was going to say about that. There is this lore of eating your shoes. It's been around a long time. It's been shared in ledgers over history in extreme starvation situations.
生吃的话。生吃，是的，但如果我把它煮了呢？它依然是在化学物质里煮出来的。我想也是。难道我们不记得，就像在老动画片里，你会看到动画片里的角色煮他们的鞋子吗？好吧，关于这个我想说的是。一直以来都有关于吃鞋子的传说。它存在很久了。历史上在极端的饥荒情况下，航海日志中曾多次记载过这件事。
For example, Sir John Franklin was a British Royal Navy officer and explorer, and in his ledger from his ship between 1819 and 1822, things were not going well. He was losing his crew to starvation, and the survivors even attempted to eat their own leather boots. And this is what gained Franklin the nickname of the man who ate his boots. And he survived, but this was in ye olden days. Maybe the leather hadn't been so treated. But everything the internet says is, do not try this.
例如，约翰·富兰克林爵士是一位英国皇家海军军官和探险家，在他1819年至1822年航行期间的船只日志中，情况非常糟糕。他的船员因饥饿不断死去，幸存者甚至试图吃掉他们自己的皮靴。这就是让富兰克林赢得“吃靴子的男人”这个绰号的原因。他活了下来，但这毕竟是老早以前的事了。也许那时的皮革还没经过那么多处理。但互联网上所有的说法都是：切勿尝试。
Okay. Well, good to know. I remember reading this fascinating book. I wish I could remember what it was, but it was about an old ship. You know, they were explorers on a ship. And, you know, there was a lot of superstition when you were a sailor, and their whole ship was getting sick and people were dying of scurvy. And they thought it was like bad luck, you know? And then they eventually landed on an island that had fruit. And they all ate some fruit and they were cured of their scurvy. And then that's when they realized, oh my gosh, we just need like a thimble full of lemon juice a day and then you don't get scurvy. But they didn't know. They didn't know. They didn't know. Well, I do think this is one of those times where Dwight had a little bit of some historical tidbit where people ate their leather shoes when they were starving and ye olden times. But no, do not attempt at home. Well listen, why
好吧。好吧，知道了。我记得读过一本很迷人的书。我希望我能想起那是什么书，但它是关于一艘旧船的。你知道的，他们是船上的探险家。而且，你知道的，当水手的时候有很多迷信，他们的整艘船都生病了，人们死于坏血病。他们以为这是某种霉运，你知道的？然后他们最终登上了一个有水果的岛屿。他们都吃了一些水果，坏血病就被治好了。然后他们才意识到，哦天哪，我们只需要每天来一小顶针的柠檬汁，就不会得坏血病了。但他们以前不知道。他们不知道。他们不知道。好吧，我确实觉得这就是那种情况：德怀特掌握了一些历史冷知识，关于老早以前人们在挨饿时会吃皮靴充饥。但是，千万不要在家尝试。好了，听着，为什么
don't we take a break and when we come back we are gonna learn Michael's rule number four for business and we're gonna get into what movies people would watch on a desert island. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game. Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial habits. Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month.
我们不休息一下，等回来后，我们将了解迈克尔的商业第四条规则，并讨论大家在荒岛上会看什么电影。你正在轻松搞定账单？战胜你的每月账单。听起来你正处于财务巅峰状态。使用BMO Eclipse Rise Visa卡来提升你的财务水平。这张信用卡能奖励你良好的财务习惯。每月按时全额支付信用卡账单即可赚取积分。
Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. With tons of free reality shows, you are totally free to watch what you love on Pluto TV. And for me, that's Dance Moms, Bar Rescue, The Challenge, and Jersey Shore. All totally free on Pluto TV. Stream now, pay never. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure.
从账单支付者蜕变为奖励收割者。适用条款和条件。在Pluto TV上，有海量的免费真人秀节目，你可以随心所欲地观看你喜爱的节目。对我来说，那就是《舞蹈妈妈》、《酒吧救援》、《挑战》和《泽西海岸》。在Pluto TV上完全免费。随时观看，永不付费。暂停你正在听的内容，开启你的下一场冒险之旅。
Stay two nights and get a $50 Best Western gift card. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Visit bestwestern.com for complete terms and conditions. for complete terms and conditions. All right, we are back and we've got rule number four from Michael and Andre Agassi. Rule number four is image is everything. I'm so sorry, I thought rule number four
入住两晚即可获得50美元的贝斯特韦斯特礼品卡。生活就是一场旅行。在贝斯特韦斯特尽情享受吧。访问bestwestern.com了解完整的条款和条件。了解完整的条款和条件。好的，我们回来了，我们要公布迈克尔和安德烈·阿加西的第四条规则。第四条规则是：形象就是一切。非常抱歉，我以为第四条规则
was failure is not an option. No, things change. Okay, clearly. This is when Michael's also gonna show off his car to Ryan. He loves that car. He really does. But you know what? His car is like a way to impress people.
是失败不是选项。不，情况会变的。好吧，很明显。这就是迈克尔向瑞安炫耀他的车的时候。他太爱那辆车了。他是真的很爱。但你知道吗？他的车是给别人留下好印象的一种方式。
It's a marketing tool. I mean, Ryan's already seen his car. Ryan has meticulously cleaned out his car in the episode Hot Girl, but Michael's gonna show it to him again. Mm-hmm. And then they're gonna sit in the backseat of it and talk. We'll get to that. Up next Jim is gonna ask everyone for their movies that they would want to watch on a desert island.
它是一个营销工具。我的意思是，瑞安已经看过他的车了。瑞安在《辣妹》那一集里还仔细清理过他的车，但迈克尔又要给他看一次。嗯。然后他们会坐在车后座上聊天。我们待会儿会聊到这个。接下来，吉姆要问大家在荒岛上想看什么电影。
And in the superfan episode we're gonna hear what Toby's picks were. I know I loved that. They are Say Anything, The Shining, and Annie Hall. Jim can't believe it. Yeah Jim's like those are some of my favorite movies too. And then he has a talking head with Pam where Jim says, you know, Toby and I used to sit together, but Michael separated us because we talked too much. So here's my question. Okay, that was a super fan added nugget.
在超级粉丝版里，我们会听到托比的选择是什么。我知道，我太喜欢这个了。它们是《单身一枝花》、《闪灵》和《安妮·霍尔》。吉姆简直不敢相信。对，吉姆觉得那些也是他最喜欢的电影。然后他和帕姆有个单人访谈，吉姆在里面说，你知道的，托比和我以前经常坐在一起，但迈克尔把我们隔开了，因为我们聊得太多了。所以我的问题是。好吧，那是一个超级粉丝版的加料彩蛋。
We're learning that Jim and Toby used to sit near one another but they talked too much so Michael separated them. Two things, number one I could see Michael hating Toby because Jim likes him. Right. Right. Jim the popular one, the one that Michael wants to be his best friend. Yeah. So he's gonna separate that because that keeps Jim all to himself. But these two guys who were bro-ing out at work, who were bonding, just because they got separated, they can't be friends. Like, why do we see no signs of this friendship anywhere else ever? They're just, that's it. That's all it took.
我们了解到吉姆和托比以前坐得很近，但他们聊得太多了，所以迈克尔把他们分开了。两件事，第一件事，我能理解迈克尔讨厌托比，因为吉姆喜欢他。没错。没错。吉姆是那个受欢迎的人，是迈克尔想要成为他最好朋友的那个人。所以他要把他们分开，因为这样才能把吉姆完全留在自己身边。但这两个在工作中有说有笑、建立起深厚友谊的家伙，仅仅因为被分开了，就不能做朋友了吗？为什么我们在其他任何地方都看不到这种友谊的痕迹？就这样，没了。就这么简单。
I don't know. I can't speak to the dude-dom, but that tracks to me. It's like, I don't know, one year, like, you know, your son plays on a sports team or something and has buddies and then that team gets broken up and they play on different teams and then you don't see those people again. I don't know. I guess.
我不知道。我没法代表男人们的友谊，但这很符合逻辑。就像，我不知道，有一年，就像，你知道的，你儿子加入了某个运动队或者别的什么，有了好哥们，然后那个球队解散了，他们去了不同的球队，然后你就再也见不到那些人了。我不知道。大概吧。
I don't know, I thought it was strange. All right, we're gonna hear Meredith's movie picks now. You might remember, they are Legends of the Fall, My Big Fat Greek Wedding, Legally Blonde, Bridges of Madison County, and then later, she'll let us know she also likes just one scene from Ghost. Just the clay pot making scene. Mm-hmm, and we need to discuss this because Pam is going to say that she kind of likes Meredith's
我不知道，我觉得这很奇怪。好吧，我们现在要听听梅雷迪思的电影选择了。你可能还记得，它们是《秋日传奇》、《我的盛大希腊婚礼》、《律政俏佳人》、《廊桥遗梦》，后来她还告诉我们，她其实还很喜欢《人鬼情未了》里的一个片段。仅仅是做陶器的那个片段。嗯，我们需要讨论一下这个，因为帕姆要说她其实挺喜欢梅雷迪思的
picks, particularly Legally Blonde. And this is going to lead to a big debate we had the first time. Mm-hmm. Because Jim is going to give her grief about Legally Blonde. He's going to say, it's not guilty pleasure movies. Yeah. And then Pam's like, OK, you're right. I take it back.
选择的，尤其是《律政俏佳人》。这引发了我们第一次录制时的一场大辩论。嗯。因为吉姆要为《律政俏佳人》数落她。他会说，这不是那种带着负罪感的快乐电影。对。然后帕姆就说，好吧，你说得对。我收回刚才的话。
I take it back. Yeah. She takes it back that Legally Blonde is not one of her desert island movie picks. OK, just hold that. Hold that. We'll get back to it. Well, in the super fan episode, we also learned Kevin's picks.
我收回。对。她收回了《律政俏佳人》是她的荒岛电影选择之一的说法。好了，先别急。记下这个。我们待会儿再聊。好吧，在超级粉丝版里，我们还知道了凯文的选择。
They are Cannonball Run, Cannonball Run 2, Weekend at Bernie's, Weekend at Bernie's 2, and Groundhog Day. And Kevin is giggling the whole time he's saying these. Yes. Stanley says, you know what, I have a client who watches Groundhog Day regularly, and maybe Kevin and him could get together and talk about that account. And Jim's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, this is sounding way too much like work let's focus here we're playing games now Dwight and Michael are gonna check out Ryan's car mm-hmm and we got some comments in the Instagram feed that I wanted to discuss okay particularly from Amy B in Franklin Tennessee who said I randomly paused the
它们是《炮弹飞车》、《炮弹飞车2》、《周末夜狂欢》、《周末夜狂欢2》和《土拨鼠之日》。凯文说出这些名字的时候一直在咯咯笑。是的。斯坦利说，你知道吗，我有一个客户经常看《土拨鼠之日》，也许凯文可以和他聚聚，聊聊那个客户。然后吉姆就说，哇，哇，哇，这听起来太像工作了，我们专注于此吧，我们现在在玩游戏。现在德怀特和迈克尔要去看瑞安的车了。嗯。我们在Instagram动态里收到了一些评论，我想拿出来讨论一下。
episode around nine minutes and 20 seconds and saw the camera guy leap out of frame. All right, I went and checked. Yes, in the original episode, you can see Matt Sohn jumping out of frame at this moment as Dwight and Michael and Ryan are all walking up to the back of Ryan's car. But in the super fan episode,
特别是来自田纳西州富兰克林的艾米·B，她说我在大约9分20秒的时候随机暂停了剧集，看到摄像师跳出了画面。好吧，我去检查了一下。是的，在原版剧集中，你可以看到马特·索恩在这个时候跳出了画面，当时德怀特、迈克尔和瑞安正一起走向瑞安的车尾。但在超级粉丝版里，
this scene happens at 16 minutes and six seconds, and I don't know if they used a different take or if they just tightened the shot, because you can do that in editing. You can kind of like push in. Push in. Matt's zone is not there anymore. Matt's zone, you have been wiped out of the superfan
这个场景发生在16分06秒，我不知道他们是不是用了不同的镜头，或者他们只是把画面裁切了，因为剪辑的时候可以做到这一点。你可以做推镜头。推镜头。马特·索恩已经不在了。马特·索恩，你已经被从《火灾》的超级粉丝版里抹去了。他们稍微做了一点清理。确实。好吧，当他们查看瑞安的车时，迈克尔看到瑞安车里有一堆大号的、像大学课本一样的教科书。就在那时，瑞安说，你知道我在上夜校。现在瑞安要开始就商业问题考考迈克尔了。对。这是第一个问题。
episode of The Fire. They did a little tidy ink. They did. Well, while they're checking out Ryan's car, Michael sees a bunch of big like class-like sized textbooks in Ryan's car. And that's when Ryan says, you know what, I'm in night school. And now Ryan is going to start quizzing Michael on business. Yeah. Here's the first question.
为什么过去几年人们一直在重新思考微软模式？第一个问题把迈克尔给问懵了。他完全不知道。第二个问题，当美元上涨时，这对美国商业有什么影响？迈克尔说，过。又是完全不知道。好吧，现在迈克尔要在超级粉丝版里进行单人访谈了。他会说，你知道的，我在快餐店工作过，后来又在一个卖能切开硬币的餐具的地方工作过，这是瑞安没有的生活经验。好吧，天哪，在看这些超级粉丝版时，我还会回去重看删减片段，看看里面是不是包含了所有内容。在这种情况下，他们略微删减了一点删减片段里的内容，迈克尔在其中实际上分享了他在成长过程中在哪家快餐店工作过。他在哪里工作过？
Why have people been rethinking the Microsoft model in the past few years? First question stumps Michael. He has no idea. Second question, when the dollar goes up, what does that do to American business? Michael says pass. Again, no idea. Well, now Michael is do to American business? Michael says pass. Again, no idea.
阿比斯（Arby's）。不会吧。真的。他说他在Arby's工作过。你以前在快餐店工作过吗？因为我高中时在一家快餐店工作过。我在长约翰银鱼（Long John Silver's）工作过。没有，但我高中时最好的朋友在冰雪皇后（Dairy Queen）工作过。我们会把车开过得来速窗口，然后说，嘿，你们在干嘛呢？
Well now Michael is gonna have this talking head in the superfan episode. He's gonna say, you know, I worked at a fast food restaurant and then I worked at a place that sold cutlery that could cut through a penny, which is life experience that Ryan doesn't have. Well lady, in watching these superfan episodes I also go back and I rewatch the deleted scenes to see if everything is included. And in this case, they omitted just a little bit that was in deleted scenes where Michael actually shares which fast food restaurant he worked at growing up. Where did he work?
然后她会跟我们聊一会儿，接着她就会挨训。他们会说，艾米，快回来。别跟你们的朋友聊天了。我们开车过去就是为了跟她聊天。我高中时当过救生员。哦，我明白了。我的第一份工作是在一家宠物收容所。我当时只有15岁。我父母周末得开车送我去，我要清理狗舍，
Arby's. No way. Yes. He says he worked at Arby's. Did you ever work in fast food? Because I worked at a fast food restaurant in high school. I worked at Long John Silver's. No, but my best friend in high school worked at Dairy Queen. And we would drive through the drive-through and be like, hey, what are you doing?
跟小狗玩耍。哦，我太喜欢这份工作了。就好像我喜欢照顾所有的动物。然后我的第二份工作是在长约翰银鱼。后来我在洗车行工作了三年。我负责把车擦干。我已经在播客里讲过这些故事了吗？我都不知道。不过，由于我是洗车行里仅有的几个女员工之一，我个子比较小，能挤进后座，我会喷洗内部车窗，那就是我的工作。我得飞快地爬进车里，把所有的内部车窗都擦干净，而小伙子们则在车子洗完出来时擦干车身外部。你知道的，里面有很多化学气味。
And then she'd hang out for a little bit, and then she'd get fussed at. They'd be like, Amy, come back. Stop talking to your friends. We'd just drive up to talk to her. I lifeguarded in high school. Oh I see. My very first job was at a kennel. I was only 15. My parents had to drive me on the weekends and I would clean out the kennels and
我在这些气味里待了很长时间。有很多化学气味。是的。这是我的一个鸡尾酒会小绝活。我可以模仿喷雾瓶的声音，比如那种你——安吉拉带来的又一个音效，让我们听听。准备好了吗？所以想象我正拿着一个喷雾瓶。就像，你知道我的意思吗？
play with the puppies. Oh I loved this job. It was like I love taking care of all the animals. And then my second job was at Long John Silver's. And eventually I worked at a car wash for three years. I would dry off the cars. Have I told these stories already on the podcast? I don't even know. But since I was one of the only girls that worked the car wash, I was tinier and I could fit in the back seat and I would spray the interior windows and that was my job. I had to crawl in the car really quickly and do all the interior windows while all the fellas dried off the outside of the car when it came out of the car wash. You know it was very fume-y.
我知道，对，Windex（玻璃清洁剂）。Windex，我拿着Windex。玻璃清洁剂。准备好了吗？嗞，嗞，嗞，嗞，嗞，嗞。非常好，安吉。不客气。不客气。
I spent a lot of time in these fumes. Very fume-y. Yeah. This is a cocktail party trick of mine. I can do the sound of like a spray bottle, like a bottle that you- Another sound effect from Angela, let's hear it. Ready? So imagine I'm holding a spray bottle. Like, you know what I mean?
2025年也是安吉拉大显身手做音效的一年。我太支持了。非常好，安吉。不客气。不客气。2025年也是安吉拉大显身手做音效的一年。我太支持了。你想知道关于商业知识测验的下一个问题吗？在这里。签下一个新客户划算，还是留住一个现有客户划算？瑞安说签一个新客户的成本要贵10倍。瑞安说签一个新客户的成本要贵10倍。嗯。嗯。迈克尔现在有一个单人访谈，在里面他说，你知道的，我可能没去过商学院，
I know, yeah, Windex. Windex, I'm holding Windex. Glass cleaner. Ready? Tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk. Very good, Ange. You're welcome. You're welcome.
但勒布朗·詹姆斯、特雷西·麦克格雷迪或科比·布莱恩特也没有去过。他们都直接进了NBA，这根本不是一回事。我知道。这真是一个不同寻常的单人访谈。我知道。好吧，我得看看有没有备用的糖果袋片段。有吗？有的。迈克尔本会这么说，你知道的，这只是，当时的人们没有那么有野心。那是八十年代，你知道的，那是一个更加单纯的年代，用来解释他为什么没去读商学院。好吧，我想为了致敬这个商学院测验，
2025 is also the year of Angela doing sound effects. I'm here for it. Very good, Ange. You're welcome. You're welcome. 2025 is also the year of Angela doing sound effects. I'm here for it. Would you like to know the next question in the quiz about business? Here it is. Is it cheaper to sign a new customer or keep an existing customer? Ryan says it's 10 times more expensive to sign a new customer. Ryan says it's 10 times more expensive to sign a new customer. Hmm. Hmm. Michael now has a talking head where he says, you know, I might not have gone
也许是时候进行我们的下一轮测验了。萨姆，你有问题吗？是的，我有。好啦，卡西，准备好了吗？你打算改规则吗？我可能会。好吧，你这次打算出什么类别的题？其实我要从茶壶的问题里出题。
to business school, but neither did LeBron James or Tracy McGrady or Kobe Bryant. They all went to the NBA, which isn't the same thing at all. I know. It's such an unusual talking head. I know. Well, I had to see if there was a candy bag alt for it. Is there? There is. Michael would have said this, you know, it's just, people weren't so ambitious. It was the eighties, you know, it was a more innocent time on why he didn't go to business school. Well, I think in honor of this business school quiz,
哦，他又回到了茶壶的问题。在《受伤》那一集里，迈克尔想让帕姆把哪种黄油抹在他烧伤的脚上？我听到“boing-oing”的声音了。人造黄油。不对。哦，该死。珍娜。
it might be time for another round of our quiz. Sam, do you have the questions? Yes, I will. All right, Cassie, you ready? Are you going to change the rules? I might. OK, what are you asking from this time? I'm going to ask from the teapot, actually.
Country Crock（农村陶罐牌人造黄油）。答对了。答对了。在《员工调动》那一集里，当迈克尔说“事不过四”时，开往纳舒厄的车上收音机里在放什么歌？哦，该死。
Oh, he's going back to the teapot. In the injury episode, what type of butter did Michael want Pam to rub on his burnt foot? I heard the boing-oing. Margarine. Nope. Oh, shoot. Jenna.
我能听到。我也能。哦，天哪。我想起来了。是，生命是一条高速公路（Life Is a Highway）。答对了。对，对。答对了。
Country croc. That's right. That is right. In the employee transfer episode, what song was on the radio on the drive to Nashua when Michael says, fourth time's a charm? Oh, shoot.
好啦。在《工作》那一集里，迈克尔以为他要在总公司得到一份工作。他在哪个网站上以创纪录的速度卖掉了他的公寓？我都记不清他做过这事了。他卖掉公寓是因为他以为自己能得到那份工作。没错，在eBay上。eBay！
I can hear it. I can too. Oh, gosh. I have it. Was it, life is a highway. That's right. Yeah, yeah. That's right.
答对了。哦，没人答对那个。太搞笑了。在《药物检测》那一集里，迈克尔是在谁的演唱会上被人塞了一根大麻烟的？珍娜？阿兰妮斯·莫里塞特？不对，接近了。
All right. In the job episode, Michael thought he was getting a job at corporate. What website did he sell his condo on in record time? I don't even remember him doing that. He sold his condo because he thought he was getting the job. Yep, on eBay. eBay!
哦！艾米·格兰特。不对。所以首字母是对的。只是因为她们长得有点像。艾莉西亚·凯斯。就是这个。我只记得是个A开头的名字。
That's right. Oh, no one gets that one. That's very funny. In the drug testing episode, whose concert was Michael at when he was passed a joint? Jenna? Alanis Morissette? No, close.
是的。我只能记住这些了。好啦。在《八卦》那一集里，当安迪跟奥斯卡谈论同性恋幻想时，哪个名人曾试图勾搭安迪？布拉德·皮特。答对了。
Oh! Amy Grant. No. So first letter is correct. Just because they look similar. Alicia Keys. That's it. I just knew it was an A name.
呜呼。好啦。就这样。哇。珍娜，你这一轮表现不错。谢谢。是的，我以四分领先。安吉拉、卡西，你们各自有三分。
Yes. That's all I could remember. All right. In the gossip episode, when Andy was talking to Oscar about a gay fantasy, which celebrity tried to get to Andy? Brad Pitt. That's right.
好的。好啦。是的，我以四分领先。安吉拉，卡西，你们各自有三分。好吧。好吧，轮到帕姆分享她的荒岛电影选择了。以下是她的选择。它们是《冰血暴》、《剪刀手爱德华》、《年少轻狂》、《早餐俱乐部》、《公主新娘》。她还有一个历来最爱的电影，但吉姆不让她加进去。你知道我觉得《办公室女士6.0》可以加入的一个有趣环节是什么吗，那就是我们重温
Woohoo. All right. That's it. Wow. That was a good round for you, Jenna. Thank you. Yes, I'm leading with four points. Angela, Cassie, you each have three.
大家的荒岛电影并对它们进行深度解析？对。我觉得唯一的难点在于要过完凯文的片单可能会有点吃力。天哪。不过这些可以激发一些有趣的电影解析。我觉得我没法重温《周末夜狂欢2》。我的意思是，他们还能搞出多少恶作剧？你知道的，我们第一次做这个解析时，你和我分享了我们的电影选择。我分享的电影选择是《边缘》、《三个 amigo》、《宝贝小情人》、《母女情深》和《寄生虫》。安吉拉，你的是《拜见岳父大人》、《傲慢与偏见》、《走出非洲》、《黑客帝国》、《帝国反击战》、
OK. All right. Yes, I'm leading with four points Angela, Cassie, you eat Chopped 3. Okay. All right, it is Pam's turn to share her Desert Island movie picks. Here's what they are. They are Fargo, Edward Scissorhands, Dazed and Confused, Breakfast Club, Princess Bride. And she has an all time favorite that Jim will not let her add. You know something I thought could be fun for Office Lady 6.0 is what if we did
《莎翁情史》，而且你说你差点选择“根本不看电影，只看唐顿庄园”。我觉得重新审视我们的选择，并把萨姆和卡西也拉进对话中会很有趣。所以我想先问，你会更改你的任何选择吗？我的意思是，我最近刚看了《傲慢与偏见》。
rewatches of people's desert island movies and do breakdowns of them? Yeah. I think the only it would be a little tough to go through Kevin's list. Oh man. But these could inspire some fun movie breakdowns. I don't think I could do Weekend at Bernie's 2. I mean, how much more shenanigans can they get up to? You know, the first time we did this breakdown, and you and I shared our movie choices. I shared that my movie choices were The Edge, The Three Amigos, Tootsie, Terms of
我太喜欢了。我一遍又一遍地重看那部电影。所以那仍然是我的首选。我永远都会把《黑客帝国》保留在名单里，永远。当然。这次我可能会把《当哈利遇到莎莉》加进去。哦，是的。我太喜欢那部电影了。
Endearment, and Parasite. Angela, yours were Meet the Parents, Pride and Prejudice, Out of Africa, The Matrix, The Empire Strikes Back, Shakespeare in Love, and you said you almost chose No Movies movies just down the abbey. I thought it could be fun to revisit our choices and also include Sam and Cassie in the conversation. So I guess first up, and would you change any of your choices? I mean, I just watch Pride and Prejudice.
是的。还有，我真的很喜欢《肖申克的救赎》。好的。这里有一个抛给你们大家的重磅好球，因为我太喜欢这部电影了。它叫《贤妻》。真的非常棒。演员们的表现太惊艳了。
I love it. I rewatch that movie over and over. So that's still top of the list for me. I would always keep The Matrix in, always. Sure. I might include this time around When Harry Met Sally. Oh, yes. I just love that movie.
主演是格伦·克洛斯和乔纳森·普雷斯。格伦·克洛斯和乔纳森饰演一对夫妻。他是一位著名作家，而她是他的妻子。我不想给你们剧透，但它真的太引人入胜了。好吧。我得去看看这部。哦，珍娜，我太喜欢了。
Yes. And then also, I do love Shawshank Redemption. OK. And here's a curve ball for you guys because I love this movie. It's called The Wife. And it is so good. The performances are amazing.
好吧。你看完之后必须给我打电话。它的层次感太丰富了。他们的关系层次太丰富了。总之，好吧。好吧，我看完之后会给你打电话。我所有的电影都不变，除了其中一部。我要把《寄生虫》去掉。我当时刚看过它。结果发现我从来没有重看过去。我真的很喜欢它，但
It's Glenn Close and Jonathan Price. And Glenn Close and Jonathan are married. He is a famous author and she is his wife. I don't want to ruin it for you guys, but it is so compelling. All right. I'm gonna have to check that out. Oh, Jenna, I love it.
我要用《月色撩人》来替换它。不，我太喜欢《月色撩人》了。对，那是我会经常看的一部。我太喜欢了。好啦，萨姆、卡西，请说出你们的荒岛电影。好吧，我也会选《公主新娘》和《肖申克的救赎》。哦，我喜欢《公主新娘》。还有《双胞胎姐妹》和《我爱你菲利普·莫里斯》。什么是《双胞胎姐妹》？
Okay. I need you to call me after you watch it. It is so layered. Their relationship is so layered. Anyway, okay. Okay, I will call you after I watch it. I'm gonna stick with all of my movies except for one. I'm gonna get rid of Parasite. I had just seen it at the time. Turns out I haven't ever rewatched it. I really loved it, but
《双胞胎姐妹》是克里斯汀·韦格和比利·海德尔主演的。他们饰演兄妹。哦，对，对，对。是的，真的很好，它把自杀、失落和悲伤处理得非常出色。哦，我没看过。真的很好看。现在才四个，你还有一个名额，萨姆。第五个，我要选《火箭人》。
I'm gonna replace it with Moonstruck. No, I love Moonstruck. Yeah, that's one that I watch a lot. I love it so much. All right, Sam Cassie or Desert Island movies, please. All right, I'm gonna go with Princess Bride and Shawshank Redemption as well. Oh, I love Princess Bride. As well as Skeleton Twins and I Love You Philip Morris. What is Skeleton Twins?
啊，那是一部很温馨的电影，我知道，对。好啦，卡西，你的片单是什么？好吧，你们发邮件问过这个，我以为你们是想知道我们最喜欢的荒岛电影是什么。哦，所以你最喜欢的荒岛电影是什么？这真是一个转折。对，所以我选了《瑞士军刀男》。现在我脑子里想象的是自己在一个荒岛上看着一部关于荒岛的电影。但如果我要选五部电影的话，我会选《底线》、《谋杀绿脚趾》、《白水镇》、《闪灵》和《E.T.外星人》。
Skeleton Twins is Kristen Wiig and Bill Hader. They play siblings. Oh yes, yes, yes. Yes, it's really good, deals with suicide and loss and grief very well. Oh, I haven't seen that. It's really good. Now that's only four, you get one more, Sam. For the fifth one, I'm gonna pick The Rocketeer.
《Skeleton Twins》由克里斯汀·韦格和比尔·哈德主演。他们饰演兄妹。哦，对，对，对。对，这部电影真的很好，把自杀、失落和悲伤处理得非常出色。哦，我还没看过那部。真的很好。现在这只有四部，山姆，你还有一个名额。第五部，我选《火箭人》。
Aw, that's a sweet movie, I know it, yeah. All right, Cassie, what's your list? Okay, you emailed us about this, and I thought you wanted to know what our favorite deserted island movie was. Oh So what is your favorite deserted island movie? This is a twist. Yeah, so I picked Swiss Army man And now I'm just imagining myself on an island watching a deserted island movie But if I was picking five movies, I'd go with Bottoms, Big Lebowski, Billy Madison, The Shining, and E.T.
哦，那是一部很温馨的电影，我知道，对。好了，卡西，你的片单是什么？好的，你为此给我们发了邮件，我以为你是想知道我们最喜欢的荒岛电影是什么。哦，那你最喜欢的荒岛电影是什么？这真是一个转折。是的，所以我选了《瑞士军刀男》。现在我只是想象自己在一个岛上看着一部荒岛电影。但如果让我选五部电影，我会选《Bottoms》、《谋杀绿脚趾》、《白标》、《闪灵》和《E.T.外星人》。
Oh, I love E.T. and I love The Big Lebowski. Yeah. Well, three comedies, a horror, and then one that just tugs at your heartstrings. Pretty good list. Thanks. Well, now we're back in Ryan's car and Angie you like to assign things a cringe meter. I'm gonna give this a cringe of nine. This is where things have taken a turn and Michael has started just confessing that he went
哦，我喜欢《E.T.外星人》，我也喜欢《谋杀lebowski》。是的。嗯，三部喜剧，一部恐怖片，然后是一部触动你心弦的片子。相当不错的名单。谢谢。好了，现在我们回到了瑞恩的车里，安吉丽娜，你喜欢给事情打一个尴尬指数。我要给这个尴尬指数打九分。这就是事情发生转折的地方，迈克尔开始承认他进入
into sales because he loves making friends, he was promoted to manager at a young age, and on and on. Ryan is so uncomfortable, he actually says, I have grown uncomfortable with the intensity of this conversation. He needs to get out of the backseat of this car. I know, but it's so just revealing of Michael that he was probably a lot happier as a salesman because he got to interact with people and kind of butter them up and be Pally.
销售行业是因为他喜欢交朋友，他很年轻就晋升为经理，诸如此类。瑞恩太不舒服了，他竟然说：“我对这段对话的强度感到不舒服。”他需要下这辆车的后座。我知道，但这太能说明迈克尔了，他当销售员时可能快乐得多，因为他能和人互动，给他们拍马屁，和他们套近乎。
And then we're just gonna move that cringe meter right back on over across the parking lot because Jim is about to start the next game, which is Who Would You Do? Why would they play this? Why? It's a horrible idea. It's a horrible idea. It's a horrible idea.
然后我们就要把尴尬指数直接挪回停车场那边，因为吉姆要开始下一个游戏了，那就是“你会选谁”。他们为什么要玩这个？为什么？这是个可怕的主意。这是个可怕的主意。这是个可怕的主意。
Kevin and Oscar immediately say Pam. And while this is happening, Dwight is clearly just sad that Michael's spending so much time with Ryan, because now he's sitting in his car, loudly listening to Everybody Hurts. Yes, he's listening to REM's Everybody Hurts and Kent shared with me that it cost us $14,000
凯文和奥斯卡立刻说出帕姆的名字。正当这发生时，德怀特显然只是很难过迈克尔花那么多时间陪瑞恩，因为现在他正坐在自己的车里，大声听着《每个人都在受伤》。是的，他在听REM乐队的《每个人都在受伤》，肯特告诉我，播放那首歌花了他14,000美元
to play that song. Just that one song? Holy moly. Yeah. Everybody does hurt in their pocketbook. Sorry. I'm sorry. I'm turning into Josh.
就为了那首歌？天哪。是的。每个人的钱包确实都在受伤。对不起。对不起。我正在变成乔什。
This is like a dad joke. That was a dad joke. Sorry. And lady, we talked about this in our original breakdown, but I just want to bring it back up again. I don't like Jim and Pam in this scene. They're making fun of Dwight. They are, and they are mean.
这就像个老爸笑话。那是个老爸笑话。对不起。蕾迪，我们在最初的剧本解析里聊过这个，但我只想再提一下。我不喜欢这个场景里的吉姆和帕姆。他们在取笑德怀特。他们确实在取笑，而且他们很刻薄。
I'm just saying it again. But I didn't love Jim and Pam in this whole episode. I kind of thought that they were being too cool for school, they were laughing at other people's expense a lot. This was so early for me to kind of like turn on them in this way, but in rewatching this, I was like, I'm not loving it guys. I know it's the too cool for school thing. I don't care for that. Let people like what they like.
我只是再重申一遍。但我整集都不太喜欢吉姆和帕姆。我有点觉得他们表现得太装酷了，他们经常在别人身上找乐子。我这么快就开始对他们粉转黑，这对我来说有点早，但在重看时，我觉得：伙计们，我实在喜欢不起来。我知道这就是那种装酷的调调。我不太喜欢这样。让别人喜欢他们喜欢的东西吧。
Let them like whatever movies they like. Let them be happy. We did have a comment about this scene where Jim and Pam go over to Dwight. Mm-hmm. From Kristen W. in Pasadena, California. She says, were John and Jenna breaking when they were talking to Dwight in his car? Did Rain improvise the line about Ryan dying in the war? It looked like they were all trying to stop laughing and then just keep going on with the scene. Kristen, that was all scripted.
让他们喜欢他们想看的任何电影吧。让他们开心吧。关于这个场景，我们确实收到了一个评论，吉姆和帕姆走到德怀特车前。嗯。来自加利福尼亚州帕萨迪纳的克里斯汀·W。她说，约翰和詹娜跟车里的德怀特说话时笑场了吗？雨恩是即兴发挥关于瑞恩在战争中牺牲的那句台词吗？看起来他们都在极力憋笑，然后硬着头皮演下去。克里斯汀，那是全剧本写好的。
Ryan in the war was scripted, and it was also scripted that Pam and Jim were trying to suppress laughter as they talked to Dwight. Yes. Because they're laughing at him. I feel like I remember it was a hard choice for me because Rainn's performance is kind of heartbreaking. Like it was a little hard for me to justify
瑞恩在战争中的台词是写好的，帕姆和吉姆在跟德怀特说话时强忍笑意也是写好的。是的。因为他们在嘲笑他。我觉得我记得这对我来说是个艰难的选择，因为雷恩的表演有点让人心碎。就像我很难为之辩解
that my character was taking joy in this, but I tried to remind myself, hey, this guy is really irritating to us a lot. Like he's difficult to be around in the office, but you know, the Jenna inside of me is like, it doesn't matter. You just don't laugh at people. I know. Not when they're hurting like that.
我的角色在从中找乐子，但我试着提醒自己：嘿这家伙平时真的很烦人。他在办公室里很难相处，但你知道，我詹娜心里的声音说：这没关系。你就是不能嘲笑别人。我知道。特别是当他们受这种伤的时候。
No. matter you just don't laugh at people. I know not when they're hurting like that. No and Angela I know from our own personal experience in Hollywood the thing that irritates us the most is when we run into the too cool for schools. Oh my gosh get over yourself already. Get over yourself when we're like at an event or something yeah and you're trying to talk to someone and they're just looking over your shoulder to see if the next best person is going to come in the room and then they say snarky comments. Oh just please. You play pretend. Exactly. We're not solving the world's problems here. Just be nice. Be nice.
不。不管怎样，你就是不能嘲笑别人。我知道，当他们受那种伤的时候绝对不能。而且安吉丽娜，根据我们在好莱坞的亲身经历，最让我们恼火的就是遇到那些装酷的人。哦天哪，饶了我们吧，快成熟点吧。当我们去参加什么活动之类的，然后你试图和某人说话，而他们只是越过你的肩膀看有没有更好的人走进房间，接着说出刻薄的话。哦，求求了。你们只是在过家家。没错。我们又不是在解决世界难题。友善点吧。友善点。
It's not that hard, and that's what I want to say to Jim and Pam. One of the things I did love about this scene is that when Jim leaves to go to Dwight's car, he puts Stanley in charge, and Stanley takes it seriously. He's like, okay, Stanley's now in charge of the game. And when we cut back to the game, we don't know why, but out of the blue, Kevin just says
这没那么难，这也是我想对吉姆和帕姆说的话。我喜欢这个场景的一点是，当吉姆离开去德怀特车里时，他让斯坦利负责，而斯坦利很认真地对待这件事。他好像在说，好吧，斯坦利现在负责这个游戏了。当我们切回游戏时，我们不知道为什么，但凯文突然没头没脑地说了一句
boobs and Stanley says, what question are you responding to? Yes, that was a little added bit in the super fan episode. Roy is going to come up, you know, all the guys in the warehouse, there was a scene where they were like doing donuts and stuff and drinking beers. And he's like, these guys are a little crazy. Can I come hang out with you guys for a little bit? He says they can be real jackasses. Yeah. And this is a moment where I'm like, oh, Roy, Roy, there might be something there that's sweet about Roy. He doesn't want to just drink beer and do donuts with the jackasses. He's like, that's kind of getting old.
胸部，然后斯坦利说，你回答的是什么问题？是的，那是超级粉丝版里加的一小段。罗伊要过来，你知道的，仓库里的小伙子们，有个场景是他们在那儿飙车漂移什么的，还喝着啤酒。然后他说，这帮家伙有点疯狂。我能跟你们一起玩一会儿吗？他说他们有时真的很混蛋。是的。这是一个让我觉得，哦，罗伊，罗伊，罗伊身上可能有些可爱之处的时刻。他不想只和这帮混蛋喝啤酒和飙车。他觉得，那种生活有点过时了。
Yeah, no. Instead, he wants to join the game of who would you do and pick Angela. In front of his fiance. Yeah. That's not being a jackass. Good job, Roy. Roy is not at the place yet where he's learning how to play the piano for his fiance. No, he's not, exactly. So everyone's going around and awkwardly
是的，才怪。相反，他想加入“你会选谁”的游戏，并且选了安吉丽娜。当着他未婚妻的面。是的。这可不是不混蛋的表现。干得好，罗伊。罗伊还没达到那种为了未婚妻去学钢琴的境界。不，他还没到，确实如此。所以每个人都在尴尬地转来转去
shouting out who they would do when Ryan gets a call on his cell phone and I love it so much because he's like, no this is a good time, this is a great time. Yeah yeah yeah. And then Michael is suddenly bummed that he doesn't have his cell phone. Well Dwight says I can he doesn't have his cell phone. Well, Dwight says, I can go back and get your cell phone. I'll go in the building. I'll go in the burning building to get your cell phone, Michael. Of course, his subtext is, that's how much I love you.
大声喊出他们会选谁，这时瑞恩的手机响了，我太喜欢这个了，因为他说，不，现在是好时机，现在是绝佳时机。对对对。然后迈克尔突然很沮丧，因为他没有手机。嗯，德怀特说，我可以，他没有手机。嗯，德怀特说，我可以回去拿你的手机。我要进大楼。我要走进着火的大楼去拿你的手机，迈克尔。当然，他的潜台词是：我有多爱你就有多深。
Yes. And Michael, as Dwight runs in the building, Michael is like, you idiot. And Kevin says, he could die. And the last thing you said to him is idiot. Yeah, that's gonna weigh on Michael Well now we have a new little scene where Jim and Ryan are discussing business school. Jim's got some questions I wonder if this is kind of coming off of that Added talking head that we had earlier where Pam is saying you're not stuck at Dunder Mifflin
是的。在德怀特跑进大楼时，迈克尔说，你个白痴。凯文说，他可能会死。你对他说得最后一句话竟然是个白痴。是的，这会成为迈克尔的心头大石。好吧，现在我们有了一个新的小场景，吉姆和瑞恩在讨论商学院。吉姆有一些问题，我想这会不会是承接了之前那个加进来的谈话头，当时帕姆说你不是被困在邓德米夫林了
Mm-hmm, like she planted this seed. You could have options. Yeah. So I guess Jim's kind of looking at his options. Ryan says he sees it as an investment. Mm-hmm. The ladies are still playing the game of who would you do and pretty much everyone chooses Jim. Pam is divided between Oscar or Toby. Yep. And Michael, it's really weighing on him now that Dwight's inside the building. He's like, why is Dwight taking so long? Yeah. Katie is going to call Jim and have to step away. And Michael is going to tell Ryan, call my cell phone so Dwight can find it more easily. He's been in there too long. And then Ryan's like, well, I don't have your number. And Michael's like, but I gave it to you back in the car.
嗯，就像她埋下了这颗种子。你本可以有选择。好吧，所以我想吉姆在考虑他的选择。瑞恩说他把这看作是一项投资。嗯。女士们还在玩“你会选谁”的游戏，几乎每个人都选了吉姆。帕姆在奥斯卡和托比之间犹豫不决。是的。而迈克尔，随着德怀特进了大楼，这真的成了他的心病。他说，德怀特怎么去了这么久？凯文要给吉姆打电话，不得不走开。迈克尔要告诉瑞恩，打我手机，这样德怀特更容易找到它。他在里面待得太久了。然后瑞恩说，我没有你的号码。迈克尔说，但我刚才在车里给你了。
I saw you put it in your phone. I watched you enter it into your phone. And Ryan's like, yeah, you're gonna need to give it to me again. Cringe meter of 10. Yes. So Michael uses Ryan's phone to call his own phone. And it rings in his pocket.
我看到你把它存进手机里了。我看着你把它输入到你的手机里。瑞恩说，好吧，你得再给我一遍。尴尬指数10分。是的。于是迈克尔用瑞恩的手机拨打自己的手机。结果他的口袋里响了。
Yeah. That's when Dwight comes running out of the building and he announces how this fire started. Yeah. Ryan left his cheese pita in the toaster oven and it caught on fire. For the guy who didn't want to be a something guy. He's now fire guy. He has a great talking head where he says I can't believe I started the fire. And this is also when Dwight is gonna sing the song he made up for Ryan. Ryan started the fire. To the melody of We Didn't Start the Fire by Billy Joel,
是的。就在这时，德怀特从大楼里跑出来，宣布了这场火灾是怎么引起的。是的。瑞恩把他的奶酪皮塔饼放在小烤箱里，然后着火了。对于那个不想当“什么什么人”的家伙来说。他现在成了“着火男”。他有一个很棒的谈话头，他说我不敢相信是我引起的火灾。这也是德怀特要唱他为瑞恩编的那首歌的时候。瑞恩点燃了火。用的旋律是比利·乔尔的《我们没有点燃火》
Kent said, it only cost us $5,500 for the song. And this is because we weren't playing it. We were just singing our version of it. So we only had to get what is called sync rights. I wonder what it would have been if we played the whole thing. Maybe something closer to Everybody Hurts. Katie is going to arrive now, and she's so excited to tell Jim her desert island movie
肯特说，这首歌只花了他5,500美元。这是因为我们没有播放原版。我们只是唱了我们自己的版本。所以我们只需要获得所谓的同步权。我想如果我们播放整首会怎么样？也许会更接近《每个人都在受伤》。凯特现在要到了，她非常兴奋地告诉吉姆她的荒岛电影
picks. Yes, so Jim brings her over to the group, and she starts her list, and her very first choice is Legally Blonde. Pam laughs. Jim cuts her off. He's like, no, no, that's it. That's it. We don't. Yep. Pam laughs. Jim cuts her off. He's like, no, no, that's it. That's it. We don't.
选择。是的，所以吉姆把她带到大家中间，她开始说她的片单，她的第一选择是《律政俏佳人》。帕姆笑了。吉姆打断了她。他说，不，不，就是这个。就是这个。我们不。是的。帕姆笑了。吉姆打断了她。他说，不，不，就是这个。就是这个。我们不。
We got to go. We got to go. Now, when we first broke down the scene, we had a hot take right here. We got a lot of mail about our hot take. In our hot take, I said that I didn't like how Pam was snarkily laughing at Katie. I thought she was being competitive,
我们得走了。我们得走了。好了，当我们第一次剖析这个场景时，我们当时有一个热门观点。我们收到了很多关于这个观点的邮件。在那个观点中，我说我不太喜欢帕姆对凯蒂冷嘲热讽地笑。我觉得她很有好胜心，
but I said, you know, we know Pam likes Legally Blonde. And then you asked, why can't she just tell Jim what she likes? And I said, I know, why did she edit herself and now she's like being snarky to this other woman for something- For liking the same movie she likes. Yes, this was our discussion. Well, a lot of people had a whole different take on this.
但我说，你知道的，我们知道帕姆喜欢《律政俏佳人》。然后你问，为什么她不能直接告诉吉姆她喜欢什么？我说，我知道，她为什么要自我设限，现在她又因为某种原因对另一个女人冷嘲热讽——因为喜欢和她一样的电影。是的，这就是我们的讨论。好吧，很多人对这件事有完全不同的看法。
Kat S, Steven S, Scott G, they all felt like that laugh from Pam was Pam laughing at Jim, not at Katie. Sarah W said, I don't think in any way Pam is hypocritically laughing at Katie saying legally blonde. I think she's laughing at the irony and the surprise. And Lauren said, I read it more as a laugh at Jim because he had scoffed at it more of
卡特·S、史蒂芬·S、斯科特·G，他们都觉得帕姆的那种笑是在笑吉姆，而不是笑凯蒂。萨拉·W说，我不认为帕姆有任何虚伪地嘲笑凯蒂说《律政俏佳人》。我觉得她在笑那种讽刺和意外。劳伦说，我更多地解读为是对吉姆的笑，因为他之前对这部电影嗤之以鼻，这更像是一种
poetic justice. I could see the poetic justice. Yeah. And then Lauren C. said, I want to add that Jim hides his opinions from Katie, and that kind of makes him just as guilty in terms of editing oneself. And Tamika M. said, I actually want to stand up for Jim with the Legally Blonde thing. He never said Legally Blonde thing. He never said Legally Blonde wasn't a good movie. He just asked if it was a movie you would bring if you were stranded on an island. When Jim said it's a guilty pleasure movie, I think he made a good point.
报应。我能理解这种报应。是的。然后劳伦·C说，我想补充一点，吉姆对凯蒂隐瞒了自己的意见，从自我设限的角度来看，这让他也同样有罪。塔米卡·M说，我其实想为吉姆关于《律政俏佳人》的说法辩护。他从来没说过《律政俏佳人》不是一部好电影。他只是问这是否是那种如果你被困在荒岛上会带的电影。当吉姆说这是一部让人有点罪恶感的消遣电影时，我觉得他说得很有道理。
So a lot of opinions on our hot take. But I'm going to go back to my hot take. Okay. I think I have a proof of sass and it has nothing to do with the laugh. I'll give you the laugh. I give that maybe the laugh was oh my gosh, Jim's new girlfriend likes this movie that he thinks is silly. Fine. I win. Sort of that kind of thing. I think the proof of sass is in her talking head. And I think we should listen to it. I forgot what a super nice girl Katie is. Just good for Jim. They are so cute together.
所以大家对我们的热门观点有很多看法。但我还是要回到我的热门观点上来。好吧。我觉得我有她刻薄的证据，而且这和那个笑无关。我承认那个笑吧。我承认也许那个笑的意思是“噢天哪，吉姆的新女朋友居然喜欢这部他觉得很傻的电影。好吧。我赢了。”类似这种的。我觉得刻薄的证据在于她的访谈。我觉得我们应该听听看。我忘了凯蒂是个超级好的女孩。对吉姆真好。他们在一起太可爱了。
And what an adorable car. You know what it is. The adorable car. That's it. That's like such judgment. That is such sass. I feel like the whole thing is just dripping. Dripping with sass. The whole thing is dripping but like the nail in the coffin is adorable car. Yeah. Well, as they drive off, this is the moment where I think Pam is being manipulative and jealous.
还有多可爱的车啊。你知道那是什么。那辆可爱的车。就是这样。这简直太有评判性了。这太刻薄了。我觉得整段话都充满了。充满刻薄。整段话都充满了，但压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草是“可爱的车”。是的。好吧，当他们开车离开时，我觉得这就是帕姆表现得很有控制欲和嫉妒心的时刻。
She grabs Roy and kisses him, knowing that Jim is gonna see it. I know, we've never seen Pam display this kind of affection for Roy. I know, we've never seen Pam display this kind of affection for Roy. I know. Roy looks surprised. On their way back into the building, Michael is going to give Ryan another rule of business. It's rule number five. Don't burn the building down, safety first. Yeah, I also love that Michael tells Ryan he's gonna give him the rest of the rules tomorrow.
她抓住罗伊并吻了他，明知道吉姆会看到。我知道，我们从没见过帕姆对罗伊表现出这种程度的亲昵。我知道，我们从没见过帕姆对罗伊表现出这种程度的亲昵。我知道。罗伊看起来很吃惊。在他们走回大楼的路上，迈克尔要给瑞恩另一条商业规则。这是第五条。不要把大楼烧了，安全第一。是的，我也喜欢迈克尔告诉瑞恩他明天会把剩下的规则告诉他。
Yes, we got five rules. The rest are coming tomorrow. The episode ends with two never-before-seen talking heads, one from Dwight, and it's actually kind of a jump cut of different talking heads. I think this was probably a compilation of candy bag alts. So I think this is a really fun thing for fans to see because they can see how we would get handed these sort of similar versions of the same topic. And this one is all about Dwight kind of talking about how he is really Michael's number two, his beta to his alpha. And that's sort of the theme
是的，我们得到了五条规则。剩下的明天公布。这一集在两个从未公开过的访谈中结束，一个是德怀特的，这其实算是一组不同访谈镜头的快速剪辑。我觉得这可能是糖果袋备用镜头的合集。所以我觉得这对粉丝来说是一件非常有趣的事，因为他们可以看到我们是如何拿到关于同一个主题的这种相似版本的。而这个访谈的内容完全是关于德怀特谈论他如何真正成为迈克尔的二把手，他是迈克尔的阿尔法之下的贝塔。这差不多就是
of all of these little jump cuts. Mm-hmm. And then the whole episode ends with a new Michael talking head where he says, if he could change the life of one person, actually, you know what, that's aiming too low. He already changed two people's lives just by being born. Mom and dad.
所有这些快速剪辑的主题。嗯哼。然后整个剧集在一场全新的迈克尔访谈中结束，他说，如果他能改变一个人的生活，其实，你知道吗，那目标定得太低了。他仅仅通过出生就已经改变了两个人的生活。妈妈和爸爸。
Yep. But if he could change the lives of 5,000 people, no, maybe 10,000 people, actually even one is amazing. Yep. Yep. He's a mentor. He is. Just like Yoda, just like Mr. Miyagi.
是的。但如果他能改变五千人的生活，不，也许是一万人，其实哪怕是一个也了不起。是的。是的。他是个导师。他是。就像尤达大师，就像宫城先生。
But he's got five more rules of business that he's got to come up with now tonight. I think we're never going to hear these extra five rules. No. Right. He's never getting them. Not at all but I guarantee you Michael stressed and flop-sweated all night trying to think of them. And guess what? This is time for our final quiz. Our final round. Cassie you will be asking the questions. So in honor of Stanley I picked the pretzel. Okay. I want you to know Cassie unfortunately now that you're in the question of asking you are out. I'm in the lead with four.
但他今晚还得想出另外五条商业规则。我觉得我们永远不会听到这多出来的五条规则了。没错。对吧。他永远也想不出来了。完全不会，但我向你保证，迈克尔一整晚都在绞尽脑汁、急得满头大汗地试图想出来。你猜怎么着？现在是我们的终极问答时间。最后一轮。卡茜，由你来提问。为了向斯坦利致敬，我选了蝴蝶结。好吧。我想让你知道，卡茜，不幸的是，既然你成了提问的人，你就出局了。我以四分领先。
Sam, Angela, will I be going home with the Star Wars bag? I don't know. Let's see. Good luck everyone. Ironic. In the Andes play episode what did Michael drop on Angela, will I be going home with the Star Wars bag? I don't know, let's see. Good luck everyone. Ironic. In the Andy's play episode, what did Michael drop on the floor during the play? I heard boing, boing, boing. Bottle of wine.
萨姆、安吉拉，我会带着《星球大战》包回家吗？我不知道。我们走着瞧。祝大家好运。真讽刺。在《安迪的话剧》那一集里，迈克尔在话剧进行中把什么东西掉到了地上？我听到咚，咚，咚。一瓶酒。
Correct. Oh boy, Angela's coming in hot. We're tied now. In the chump episode, fill in the blank for Michael. If I had a gun with two bullets and I was in the room with Hitler, Bin Laden, and Toby, I would. Shoot Toby twice. Jenna, yes.
答对了。哦天哪，安吉拉来势汹汹。我们现在平局了。在《笨蛋》那一集里，请为迈克尔填空。如果我有一把有两颗子弹的枪，我和希特勒、本·拉登以及托比在一个房间里，我会。朝托比开两枪。珍娜，答对了。
Oh, I kind of jumped in at my buzzer. I hope I was the first buzzer. I think you were. Okay. Oh, sorry. Okay. In the Happy Hour episode, who beat Michael's pushup record to leave early from work?
哦，我好像抢按了蜂鸣器。希望我是第一个按的。我想是的。好的。哦，抱歉。好的。在《欢乐时光》那一集里，谁打破了迈克尔的俯卧撑纪录以便早点下班？
Stanley. Sam got it. Oh! All right. Is this the last question? This is the last one. All right, Jenna. And if you get it right, then we're tied.
斯坦利。萨姆答对了。哦！好吧。这是最后一道题吗？这是最后一题。好吧，珍娜。如果你答对了，我们就打平了。
We'll have to go to a tie break. Okay. There's a lot at stake. Okay. There's a lot at stake. Okay. In the murder episode, what was the name of Michael's character in the murder mystery game? Oh shoot. It's like a, like a French, like a like Cajun name, isn't it or something?
我们就得进入加时赛了。好吧。这关系重大。好吧。这关系重大。好吧。在《谋杀》那一集里，迈克尔在谋杀之谜游戏里的角色叫什么名字？哦该死。这就像是一个，一个法国的，像是一个卡津人的名字，对吧，还是什么的？
Mama. No, that's mine. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. I got mama. No, that's mine. Oh, yeah. I got nothing. Pass. Caleb Crawdad. Oh, I knew it was a Cajun thing.
玛玛。不对，那是我的。哦是的。哦是的。哦是的。我猜的是玛玛。不对，那我的。哦，是的。我不知道。过。卡勒布·克劳达。哦，我知道那是个卡津名字。
All right, next question. Oh, no, is that it? Do I win? I think you won. Oh, well, I don't get a chance then to tie. That was your chance. Caleb tie. That was your chance. Caleb Crawdad was your chance. Well Jenna guess what? You win the Star Wars bag of socks! Bag of socks! Bag of socks! Bag of socks! Look at the socks.
好的，下一题。哦，不，就这样吗？我赢了吗？我觉得你赢了。哦，好吧，那我连打平的机会都没有了。那是你的机会。卡勒布打平。那是你的机会。卡勒布·克劳达就是你的机会。好吧，珍娜，你猜怎么着？你赢得了《星球大战》袜子包！袜子包！袜子包！袜子包！看这些袜子。
They're amazing! They are Captain Crunch and Reese's Peanut Butter Cup socks! Woohoo! And I guess it would have been weird if I won the gift prize that I bought. Well, thank you all for listening. This was a lot of fun. A big thank you to Kent Sabornak. Yeah, and I want to say thank you to Ken Kuapus for sharing with us his memories about this episode. And I asked Ken if there's a project I could share about,
它们太棒了！它们是谷物队长和里修斯花生酱杯的袜子！呜呼！而且如果我赢了我自己买的礼物奖品，那好像也挺奇怪的。好吧，谢谢大家收听。这真的很有趣。非常感谢肯·萨伯纳克。是的，我要感谢肯·库普斯与我们分享他关于这一集的记忆。我问肯有没有什么项目我可以分享的，
and he said he is thrilled because he is directing all four episodes of the Malcolm in the Middle reboot. A lot of the main cast is coming back, and he's really excited about it. Oh, my gosh, yes, I read about that. That's so cool. Yeah, there's some great articles about it. I'll share it in our stories.
他说他非常兴奋，因为他正在执导《马尔科姆的一家》重启版的所有四集。很多主要演员都会回归，他对此感到非常兴奋。哦，天哪，是的，我读过关于那个的报道。太酷了。是的，有一些很棒的相关文章。我会把它分享到我们的快拍中。
Well, everyone, thanks for joining us and we'll see you next week. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
好了，各位，谢谢你们加入我们，我们下周见。再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberree by Creed Bratton. ["Ruppertree"] There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的执行制片人是卡茜·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉娅·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubberree》。[“Ruppertree”] 本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。